Party On Linus
Party on Tim. Logbuch - Netzpolitik, Partytime, excellent!
Logbuch:Netzpolitik. Nummer vierhundert.
Vom dreiundzwanzigsten siebten.
Zwanzig, einundzwanzig.
Einundzwanzigste, ein schönes Jahr? Dreiundzwanzigster sechster, stimmt. Oh man, jetzt haben wir auch noch das verkackt, ey.
Was? Was haben wir gesagt?
Ich habe dreiundzwanzigster siebter gesagt, ist,
dreiundzwanzigster sechster.
Läuft alles total super hier, vor allem in der Mieterebene, die äh auf einmal von Menschen bevölkert wird. Das ist wirklich ein bisschen äh verstörend. Ich bin überhaupt nicht drauf vorbereitet und zwar nicht nur mental nicht, sondern auch technisch äh gar nicht.
Ding sieht hier aus wie eine Corona-Höhle.
Ja. Ist auch einer.
Ich weiß nicht, ich dachte, Tim, du hättest deinen Lockdown mit der Familie zu Hause gemacht. Ich wusste ja nicht, dass du die ganze Zeit,
Pizza legen musstest.
Tja, so ist das halt mit Fußballfans. Wir trommen alle davon, ein Messi zu sein.
Ja, da sitzt die auf jeden Fall gelogen. Ziehen wir das durch. Ja.
Und so, ziehen wir das durch. So Leute, heute ist eine Sendung, die macht überhaupt gar keinen Sinn, weil wir haben äh keine netzpolitischen Themen am Start, aber wir haben ähm,
Gäste trifft's gar nicht so richtig, sondern wir haben unsere Co-Moderatoren oder so dabei.
Wir haben die alte Band wieder zusammen.
Wieder zusammengebracht. Genau. Das ist immer so ein bisschen so wie in diesen komischen äh Kriegsfilmen, wo dann immer irgendwelche äh total problematischen Bösewichte aufkommen und sie müssen dann so diese super Spezialisten wieder aus der Rente holen und,
so an die Tür und so.
Deswegen hat Thomas ein olivgrünes Unterhemd an.
Genau, Thomas ist äh uns zugeschaltet hier aufm Beamer. Wir versuchen hier irgendwie eine vertraute Runde zu machen. Und äh ja, hallo. Hallo Thomas.
Hallo, liebe Grüße nach Berlin.
Genau und äh dir gegenüber am Beamer ist der Andre, hallo Andre.
Hallo. Endlich wieder eine Meterebene.
Endlich wieder Meterebene.
Wann warst du letztes Mal hier, Andre?
Keine Ahnung, vor zwei Jahren oder so, irgendwann, als ich das letzte Mal da war und drüber getwittert, also als ich letzte Mal in der Sendung war, hatte ich drüber getwittert, nee, ist glaube ich schon zweieinhalb Jahre her oder so, war eine ganze Ecke.
Und äh du Thomas, warst du überhaupt schon mal hier?
In der Metaebene selber glaube ich nur zwei, drei Mal also wohl wirklich aufgezeichnet haben. Das meiste war immer remote.
Wann war das äh letzte Mal, dass du dich hörst?
Boah, mein Gott! Oh, das fragst mich jetzt so schnell. Ähm ich würde auch meinen Sohn mindestens drei, vier Jahre.
Nicht nur Corona schuld.
Nee, auch auch äh Österreich.
Ich habe hier keinerlei Aufzeichnungen dadrüber, wann hier wer wo im Studio war oder so. Das ist ein Meter Informationen, die.
Aber aufzeichnen, Tim, du kannst ja nicht einfach hier Leute in Innenräume.
Code an die Tür machen.
Habt ihr euch schon eingecheckt, hier überhaupt? Eigentlich müssten wir jetzt korrekterweise die Corona-Warn-App starten, ne? Ich mache das mal. Jetzt haben wir mal eine an äh eine Anwendung.
Echt mal machen.
Ne, so QR-Code scannen, warte mal, wo liegt man denn das an hier? Äh registrieren, ungefähr sogar. Sie planen eine Veranstaltung, zack, boom. QR-Code äh Zeugen, mehr Sicherheit für sie und ihre Gäste.
Du machst den QR-Code, ja?
Ja, ich mache den QR-Code so Ort, Einzelhandel. Was hast.
Was gibt's noch? Was kannst.
Achso, ich darf ja auswählen. Einzelhandel, Gastronomiebetrieb, Handwerksbetrieb, Arbeitsstätte, Büro.
Das sieht aus wie eine Arbeitsstätte, ganz ehrlich.
Meinst du, es könnte auch eine Bildungsstätte sein.
Nee, das nicht, dann ja, aber.
Oder eine Kulturveranstaltung. Gottesdienst wäre hier auch noch eine Variante.
Gottesdienst.
Ja, Gottesdienst, okay. Äh Bezeichnung äh LNP vierhundert, Ort Meterebene. Beginnen jetzt.
Das müssen wir jetzt twittern, oder?
Ende wieso ist das Ende? Das Ende ist jetzt genau dasselbe, dieselbe Uhrzeit wieder anfangen.
Ein bisschen länger machen.
Typischer Aufenthaltsdauer. Geben sie an.
Zwei Stunden Plus äh technische Einrichtung anderthalb, so einen halben Tag.
Drei Stunden. Vorher kommt man hier nie raus. So ähm aber das Ende muss ich jetzt hier nochmal explizit angeben. Okay, Schluss ist hier um einundzwanzig Uhr.
Dann ist Fußball und dann äh mehr geht einfach nicht, ne. So, okay, das habe ich jetzt hier, einundzwanzig Uhr. Oh, das ist aber schwer einzustellen hier, meine Fresse,
so speichern, Selbst einschicken,
Okay, jetzt bin ich selber eingecheckt und jetzt könnt ihr jetzt dürft ihr hier mal machen.
Ja. Corona-Warn. So, Moment.
Wie machen wir denn das jetzt mit dir, Thomas.
Einen, der Thomas checkt sich auch ein.
Twitterst das einfach und dann kann sich jeder einchecken, statt Veranstaltung.
Twitter den QR-Code.
Du überhaupt eine Corona-Warn er beim Staat?
Oh, warte, nee, der hat jetzt das.
Ich habe ja Stopp Corona, wir haben wir haben auch sowas, aber diesen ganzen Blödsinn mit dem Check-In, ich glaube, das äh war Selbstbeschäftigung für Deutschland. Also das ist hat Österreich überhaupt nicht irgendwie gekümmert.
Auch gar nicht, ob das überhaupt.
Dabei war das doch bei euch, der Österreicher, der den der die Corona waren. Wo bleibt die Corona-App? Oh Gott. Den hatten wir als Auto von äh hier Racelli.
Das war, das war wirklich extrem ähm zukunftsorientiert, der hat schon von einer App, wo ist die Corona-App hat er gefragt.
Ja, aber Exposé Notification ist so zwanzig zwanzig. Also wir haben uns nur um den grünen Pass gestritten und äh ja, zum Glück ist das Thema jetzt auch endlich gegessen.
Der fängt schon wieder mit Netzpolitik an.
Der kann nicht anders. Genau. Na ja, jetzt kommt natürlich die große Frage, worüber reden wir denn heute eigentlich, weil ähm wir wollten ja eigentlich nicht so richtig über Netzpolitik reden, weil wir reden jetzt seit,
was weiß ich, fast zehn Jahren über Nestpolitik hier,
und irgendwie fällt uns auch nichts neues ein dabei, ne. Wir reden immer über den gleichen Scheiß, Staatstrojaner, Urheberrecht, äh Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Na okay, ab und zu mal so Impfausweise, das war neu.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen dreht sich ja hier alles äh im Kreis.
Also in der ersten Folge steht in der Beschreibung Lokbuch-Netzpolitik ist der Versuch, das netzpolitische Geschehen, deutschsprachigen Raum, weitgehend neutral und unaufgeregt in einem regelmäßigen Podcast einzufangen. Ich glaube, das mit dem Regelmäßigkeit halbwegs geklappt.
Und der Rest.
Ich weiß es nicht, weitgehend neutral und unaufgeregt. Es wäre jetzt nicht die ersten Worte, die mir einfallen würde.
Na ja, ich würde zugeben, dass wir so in gewisser Hinsicht manchmal ein wenig von der, von dem Weg abgekommen sind, wo es dann ein bisschen ähm diverser wurde äh in der Darstellung.
Der Podcast soll dabei Einblick in die Themen, aber auch Verständnisse für die Hintergründe liefern. Ich glaube, das hat ganz gut geklappt.
Mhm. Okay, steht da noch mehr?
Netzkritik möchte gerne sehr regelmäßig erscheinen. Im Idealfall einmal pro Woche,
Dies wird uns sicherlich nicht immer gelingen, doch liegt die Betonung bei diesem Projekt auf der kurzfristigen Reflexion der Ereignisse,
interessierten aber vielleicht nicht immer involvierten Betrachter einen Zugang zu der doch manchmal sehr komplexen,
bieten soll. Der Satz ist kaputt.
Das steht jetzt auf Hintergrund, was Linus vorgelesen hat. Ich habe die Sendungsbeschreibung von LMP null null eins äh zitiert.
Auf der Webseite.
Der Podcast ist derzeit noch in einem experimentellen.
Es steht auf Hintergrund.
Wir freuen uns natürlich über jede Form des Feedbacks.
Slash about, dass der zweite Link in der Leiste oben, ja.
Geil. Das habe ich noch nie draufgeklickt.
Ja. Äh okay, haben wir.
Okay, ja.
Also ich denke, das kann man nach wie vor äh so lassen. Ja, es ist ein Versuch.
Experimenteller Zustand,
das ist schon mal ein guter Titel hier. Ähm ja, experimenteller Zustand. Wollen wir ein bisschen, also wir wollten so ein bisschen,
A und jetzt nicht so eine klare Agenda vornehmen, aber dann doch so ein bisschen aus dem Nähkästchen plaudern. Aber ich glaube, das muss man dann immer so ein bisschen wechselseitig machen. Also wir wollen euch auch gleich noch ein bisschen aus dem Nähkästchen plaudern, äh lassen so, aber vielleicht,
wo du schon so gut angefangen hast, Andre äh mit dem mit dem Blick von außen,
was kommt mich nicht so an?
Ich nehme dir die Frage ab,
ich habe mich schon eine Frage jetzt gerade eben ist mir eine eingefallen, äh du hast öfters mal erzählt, oder Linus und du hast erzählt, wie du den Linus gefragt hast, den Podcast zu starten,
Aber irgendwie hat zumindest On Record äh noch nie so jemand dich gefragt, zumindest kann ich mich nicht erinnern, wie bist du denn auf diese Idee gekommen, dieses Projekt zu starten und wie lange bist du äh wie lange ist das in dir gereift,
eh du dann irgendwann den Linus ansprechen wolltest da auf dem Camp und ansprechend konnte es kurz danach, das würde ja zu Genüge.
Der Tim natürlich auch ein bisschen Mut gebraucht, um mich anzusprechen auf dem Camp.
Bestimmt. Also ganz ehrlich, die Timeline habe ich jetzt nicht mehr so richtig aufm Zettel, aber im Prinzip, wir sind uns ja immer auf einer Party begegnet, Linus, ne, erinnerst dich hier irgendwo äh in Mitte war das irgendwie auf so einem Balkon.
So einem Essen, ne? Da waren einfach noch äh ja, kleine Runde.
Kleine Runde irgendwie. Was war denn das überhaupt? Wir dürfen jetzt keine Name.
Ich glaube, da können wir jetzt auch, also es ist tatsächlich so ein Treffen, wo wir jetzt nicht die Namen nennt und auch die äh gemeinsamen Bekannten, die dort waren. Aber ja, es war so in dieser.
Genau, gemeinsame Bekannte und dann standen wir irgendwie aufm Balkon und Ninus erzählte mir, dass er irgendwie meine Podcasts hörten, die irgendwie ganz gut findet,
und ähm ja, da habe ich irgendwie eigentlich das erste Mal von dir Kenntnis erhalten in gewisser Hinsicht und dass du halt bei Netzpolitik org, aber das war doch damals schon, ne?
Ja, Linus ist gerade Bier holen, aber der hat damals bei zwanzig elf war ja nicht och gearbeitet.
Genau, also ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr ganz genau, wann diese Party war. Ähm aber das kann jetzt nicht so mega hast du eine Ahnung.
Das Bier holt, das.
Ist, aber.
Das wird nicht mega lang vorm Camp gewesen sein, weil sonst hättest du Dinge über Monate und Jahre ausplanen müssen, das ist nicht so dein Stil, oder?
Das ist.
Doch genau das.
Doch, doch, ich kann das, das kann teilweise wirklich jahrelang äh in meinem Kopf liegen.
Also, es sind da mal, also das war ähm,
Also es sind damals so ein paar Sachen zusammengekommen. Deswegen freue ich mich auch, dass du heute hier bist, Andre. Weil ich bin, das war ja dann, also ich habe zweitausendelf,
Netzwerk Org verlassen. Und zwar um in der IT Security zu arbeiten,
Und äh ich ich bewerte es ja als mein äh wichtigsten Beitrag zur Netzpolitik Org, dass dann Andre quasi meine Stelle übernommen hat. Das war damals, das war tatsächlich damals auch noch ein ähm,
Punkt, weil das Budget von Netzpolitik Org hat, hätte jetzt auch nicht erlaubt, dass wir beide dort gleichzeitig arbeiten. Und du bist von deinem äh vorherigen Arbeitgeber gegangen? Du verdienst doch hier eigentlich erzählen?
Ich weiß nicht, welche du sagen willst. Mit.
Hat was mit einem Drucker zu.
Äh wir lenken äh bisschen ab, wir können das gerne erzählen in meinem vorheriger Arbeitgeber, bei dem übrigens auch Markus Reuter war, mein jetziger äh erneuter Kollege, bei Netzpolitik Org,
und ich bin,
direkt im Anschluss zu dir, du warst neben Markus Beckedal, der ja schon immer und ewig, ich glaube, der hat noch eine einstellige CAE Folgenummer. Ja. Ähm.
Ja. Ganz am Anfang.
Schon immer und ewig in dieser Szene unterwegs äh war.
Der spricht mal weiter, wie viel ist sogar das eingefallen?
Irgendwann konnte Markus eine Person anstellen, äh mit einer halben Stelle oder was auch immer das war, das war Linus. Ich hatte vorher schon mein Praktikum gemacht zwotausendacht äh und,
irgendwie kamst du dann aber äh dazu, dich da zu bewerben und irgendwann,
wolltest du das nicht mehr? Es war Zeit für Weiterentwicklung und ich hatte grade was anderes gesucht und das hat sich super ergeben, dass wir uns den Staffelstab in die Hand in die Hand gegeben haben,
und nicht lang später schon im ersten Januar angefangen, zwanzig zwölf bei Netzpolitik org. Habe da ziemlich schnell die Funkzellenabfragestory gemacht und was war das? Hier,
Buchnetzpolitik elf, vierundzwanzigster Januar zwanzig zwölf war ich das erste Mal im Logbuch. Also das ist alles ziemlich schnell gegangen aufm nacheinander.
Weißt du, was mir auch noch einfällt? Tim, Markus Beckedal und ich waren nämlich auch mal bei dir im Podcast,
Ich glaube fast, war das ein war das ein CRE.
Für digitale Gesellschaft.
Gesellschaft, die Netzbewegung, irgendwie sowas. Und da kannten wir uns ja auch schon,
Und das muss gewesen sein zur Gründung von digitale Gesellschaft im Zweifelsfall oder kurz danach.
Das hatte ich aber, das war dieses.
Könnte zweitausendzehn gewesen sein.
Das war dann das war, glaube ich, kein CAE, sondern wir haben das gemacht, aber das habt ihr, glaube ich, bei Netzpolitik org veröffentlicht.
Das kann gut sein, ja. Stimmt. Das war wahrscheinlich auch so.
Und das war auch noch vor LNP.
Auf jeden Fall, weil das war auf jeden Fall in dem Jahr als äh digitale Gesellschaft dann auf der Republika vorgestellt wurde,
und das kann man jetzt auch erzählen. Die Webseite von digitale Gesellschaft, die haben nämlich in der Nacht vor diesem Launch Markus Reuter und ich noch zusammengehackt.
Das war zwanzig zehn, hat sich.
Ja, zwanzig zehn war die Gründung, aber ich glaube, die Vorstellung auf der Republika, die war dann zwanzig L, da bin ich mir nicht mehr ganz sicher, das steht nicht direkt auf Wikipedia, aber es hat eine Weile gedauert, äh bis wir das vorgestellt haben,
Gründungsveranstaltung war irgendwann im Sommer,
und ich glaube erst im Mai darauf auf der Republika haben wir das dann öffentlich gelauncht, das hat einiges mit Vereinsregistereintragungen und ähm gemeinnützigkeitsbescheiden und.
Die Förderung von Grund- und Freiheitsrichten,
ist kein äh gemeinnütziger Zweck. Nee, jetzt macht alles Sinn. Ähm genau, die Förderung von Grund- und Freizeitrechten ist kein gemeinnütziger Zweck. Die Story haben wir auch schon öfter erzählt, aber es war damals bei der Gründung von digitaler Gesellschaft das Thema, dass der Antrag auf Gemeinnützigkeit,
Beim ersten Mal abge äh abschiedig beschieden wurde, ablehnend beschieden oder wie sagt man? Abgelehnt. Abgelehnt wurde, weil,
im Vereinszweck eben die Förderung von Grund- und Freiheitsrechten stand, es gibt aber in definierte Anzahl gemeinnütziger Zwecke und Grund- und Freiheitsrechte gehören nicht dazu,
Und dann musste die Satzung geändert werden und die der Verein digitale Gesellschaft wurde dann nämlich auch auf diesen zwanzig elfer Camp, was ja im August zwanzig elf in Finofurt war,
vorgestellt. Da gab's irgendwie so eine Veranstaltung, da waren dann irgendwie Markus.
Da habe ich übrigens auch noch
'ne gute Anekdote, die ist von dir Linus, ich aber hoffe ich kann dir sagen, aber das ist, glaub ich, aus irgendeinem E-Mail-Fett von dir mal, weil es wurde dann ja Grund- und Freiheitsrechte ersetzt mit Konsumentenschutz und du hast so etwa gesagt,
Konsumentenschutz verhält sich zu Grund- und Freiheitsrechten wie Sozialdemokratie zu Klassenkampf.
Das habe ich mal gesagt, ja. Äh Verbraucherschutz, da ist das bei uns in Deutschland, Thomas.
Verbraucherschutz heißt auf Englisch, ja, das sind beides sehr, sehr komische Worte. Für mich hat Verbraucher immer etwas von, es ist danach alle und das passt im Internet nicht.
Ich suche grade dieses Gespräch, das wir jetzt mal wirklich für die Erinnerung.
Das war wahrscheinlich alles zwanzig elf. Zwanzigel war wirklich ein äh Verhängnis volles Jahr in dem sich da total viel.
Da war recht viel los, ne.
Da hat sich wirklich einiges ergeben. Und wahrscheinlich war diese Gutenberg Demo, die war auch äh zwanzig elf noch.
Ja, das war im Februar zwanzig elf.
Und zwanzig.
Wenn jetzt rauskommt zwanzig elf das Internet gegründet.
Jetzt habe ich's vierter, vierter Mai zwanzig elf war dieses Gespräch, was wir geführt haben. Das war mir zum Beispiel gar nicht mehr klar, dass du da dabei warst.
Netzpolitik Podcast oder wie?
Das ist Netzpolitik, also der Netzpolitik, ORG, NPPP einhundertzehn, heißt Netzaktivismus und digitale Gesellschaft EV und es war quasi Markus Bedürfnis,
mal darzustellen, was damit jetzt eigentlich gemeint ist mit dieser Initiative, weil das so ein bisschen auf,
Schwierigkeiten in der Wahrnehmung äh stieß. Und deswegen wurde ich gefragt, ob ich das dann quasi so gegen moderieren will.
Und das kann ganz gut sein, das hatte ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt gar nicht mehr so aufm Zettel, dass das so ein bisschen der Moment war, wo ich irgendwie dann auch gecheckt habe, dass du so,
ähm ganze Sätze bilden kannst und sowas.
Ja, da brauchen die Leute immer ein bisschen länger, bis sie das bei mir merken.
Meinst du? Mittlerweile glaube ich nicht mehr.
Ich wachse.
Auf jeden Fall ist ist dann um auf die eigentliche Frage nochmal zurückzukommen in mir so ein bisschen der Plan greift, der ähm tatsächlich,
Teil eines Meterplans war, dass ich nicht so richtig durchgezogen habe, weil ich hatte eigentlich eine ganze Reihe von,
Buchsendung im Sinn. Lokbuchnetzpolitik sollte sich halt um Netzpolitik kümmern und ich äh hatte eigentlich auch noch ein Logbuchwissenschaft zum Beispiel im äh im Sinn. Dazu kam's aber aus verschiedenen Gründen dann irgendwie nicht.
Und ja, dann äh Camp war dann drei Monate später und dann weiß ich nicht, dachte ich mir einfach so, dieser Linus irgendwie, der,
Es scheint ja jetzt nicht aufs Maul gefallen zu sein und ähm,
keine Ahnung, das war halt einfach so ein Gefühl so ein Gedanke, dass das so gut passen könnte, weil ich weil ich sagen wir mal so, neue Formate,
Denke ich mir jetzt gar nicht so sehr aus, weil ich das machen will, sondern weil ich so das Gefühl habe, dafür ist die Zeit reif. Und ich hatte damals das Gefühl, Podcast ist einfach etwas, was in diesem, in diesem Bereich,
Netzpolitik, was ja damals recht,
Das hatte ja eine ganze Menge. Ähm da war ja eine ganze Menge, wie du schon sagtest, ne? Zwanzig elf ist einfach viel passiert und ähm wann war diese,
Wann war denn diese äh Laien? Von der Leinen, Zensursolargeschichte.
Auch, der war auch, war alles.
Das war auch zweitausendneunzehn elf äh zwanzig elf sind die Piraten dann glaube ich ins Berliner AGH gekommen.
Genau, also irgendwie, genau, alles, alles kam auf einmal zusammen und also es gibt äh.
Äh also es gibt äh Zensursula einen Rückblick von Andre Meister.
Meine Masterarbeit darüber.
Ernsthaft?
Und hast du am am zwanzigsten vierten zwanzig elf auf äh Netzkritik Org veröffentlicht?
Ich angestellt war.
Und wir haben uns nämlich auch dann, also ich war ja auch nicht viel länger als ein Jahr bei Netzpolitik Org. Ähm mit Praktikum und Anstellung. Da müsst ihr jetzt nochmal gucken, aber ähm,
Ich, ich weiß, ich habe ja vor kurzem mein Diplom-Zeugnis bekommen. Habe ich erzählt. Ich habe.
Auf der Blockchain.
Ich habe wirklich eine ganz tolle ganz tolle E-Mail bekommen von ähm,
ich sage jetzt einfach den Namen nicht, weil ich's mit ihr nicht abgesprochen habe. Ähm von der Mitarbeiterin meines Professors,
die damals schon, die hat also mit der habe ich viel gesprochen über äh ja meinen Arbeitsvertrag an der Humboldt-Universität ähm,
und äh so Kram, ich habe da äh an der Humboldt Universität als äh studentische Hilfskraft auch gelehrt. Ich habe ja Seminare unterrichtet,
und äh äh mit ihr wie lange Geschichte und ähm,
Jetzt ist aber mein Prof, der ist inzwischen nicht mehr in der Uni und die gute Frau hat gewechselt in das äh Prüfungsamt.
Also sie ist nicht mehr, sie ist nicht mehr für den für diesen Lehrstuhl zuständig, sondern für das äh Prüfungsamt des äh Institut für für Psychologie der äh Humboldt-Universität zu Berlin. Und,
sie schrieb mir, dieses Jahr eine Nachricht. Guten Tag Herr Neumann, bevor ich nächstes Jahr um diese Zeit in Rente gehe,
wollte ich noch einmal versuchen, ihnen ihr Diplomzeugnis zukommen zu lassen.
Wenn sie mir eine Adresse schicken, gebe ich die Unterlagen umgehend in die Post,
Ansonsten müssen die Unterlagen jetzt wieder archiviert werden. Und der Hintergrund war, die waren schon mal archiviert, weil also ich habe
Diplomverhältnis wurde mir tatsächlich überreicht. Ich war auch bei der äh Abschlussveranstaltung in der Hunduniversität. Das war wahrscheinlich zweitausendzehn. Und da hatten die aber irgendwie meinen Namen falsch gesetzt auf dem Zeugnis, irgendwas stimmte da nicht. Und dann hatte ich mit der Vorgängerin
vom Prüfungsamt hätte ich gesagt, kann man das nicht irgendwie, ne, dass das,
zeigen kann, das sieht nicht aus wie eine Fälschung, so, ne? Ja, machen wir, dann musst du das halt nochmal vom Dekan und hast du alles nicht gesehen, neu unterschrieben werden und dann habe, dann war ich aber schon bei Netzpolitik org und wollte damit nichts mehr zu tun haben. Ja, und jetzt habe ich irgendwann im
mehr zu der April zwanzig einundzwanzig wurde mir dann per Einschreiben mein mein Diplomzeugnis zugestellt. Will man nicht meinen, ne?
Also du hast es bisher eigentlich nie gebraucht.
Ich habe einfach behauptet, ich werde Diplompsychologe, der hat mich relativ weit gebracht. Jetzt habe ich auch den Beweis.
Super. Man muss eigentlich gar nicht studieren.
Man braucht auch keine, also mit mit Zeugnissen in der Blockchain, ne, geht das natürlich, entweder nicht oder doch.
Richtig gut, ja.
Aber wir wollten ja nicht über Netzpolitik reden.
Auf keinen Fall.
So und das war also Diplom zweitausendzehn und dann bin ich nämlich äh dann war ich oder war der zweitausendneun. Nee, jetzt wird irgendwann habe ich, also immer habe ich eine Nerv, weil ich sofort bei Netzmittel georg. Und nicht viel länger als ein Jahr, das weiß ich auch.
In der Zeit haben wir uns kennengelernt, aber nicht nur über äh ich weiß gar nicht, ob das zwanzig zehn äh war, das war wahrscheinlich nicht das, was ich nicht nur über,
die Arbeit und die Netzpolitik, das war natürlich so der primäre Anknüpfungspunkt, so CCC Kongress äh und sowas, aber wir kannten uns dann auch privat äh ziemlich schnell.
Genau, wir haben noch, wir haben.
Stories, die aber nicht für Podcasts.
Sind nicht für einen Podcast.
Aber zwanzig elf sehe ich gerade ähm,
als der Tim gesagt hat von der Diversifizierung seiner Podcast-Landschaft äh Tims Großes Vermächtnis und Baby neben der Metaebene und all seinen Projekten ist ja vor allem auch CRE vormals Chaos Radio Express, das,
Dann ging's los, zwotausendfünf oder so,
zwanzig elf mal kurz reingeguckt, da war tatsächlich auch jede Menge los, also Telecomics, äh wie war das damals? I-Revolution, was wir damals alles gedacht haben, durch Social Media, wird alles, also quasi,
Radiotheorie und die neunziger.
Demokratie.
Revolution in Ägypten, alles, das war große Ding noch.
Auch irgendwie hedonistische internationale bei CRE, elektrisches Geld, äh GSM Security,
Cloud-Computing Kunst, Kulturgesellschaft. Äh zwanzig elf war relativ viel los. Und da hattest du dann die Idee,
Meterebene zu diversifizieren mit weiteren Podcasts, neben dem Hauptbaby CRE äh ich weiß nicht, wie lange diese Freakshow ging, das.
Ja, Freakshow gibt's ja auch schon seit zweitausendacht und äh NSFW gab's auch schon.
War auch zu dieser Zeit, stimmt. Newshow, die dann.
Ja, also LNP ist so ein bisschen so die zweite die zweite Welle so, ne, wo ich irgendwie über diese Kernformate äh hinausgegangen bin und Raumzeit fällt, glaube ich, auch noch in zwanzig elf rein. Das ist jetzt.
Nee, da würde ich sagen, da hast du zwanzig zehn oder so mit angefangen. Oder? Kann jetzt nicht alles zwanzig elf gewesen sein.
Dezember zwanzig zehn war glaube ich die erste Sendung oder irgendwie sowas,
Na ja, aber da ist halt viel passiert. Das war so bisschen mein da hatte ich auch das Studio neu. Da bin ich äh also ich habe das hier zweitausendneun,
eingeweiht und das hat natürlich bei mir eine Menge ähm also da war ich halt einfach
könnte noch keiner Podcast, da muss ja noch viel getan werden und ähm ja, so hat sich das halt auf jeden Fall alles entwickelt. So und das ist ja dann auch so schlecht nicht gelaufen. So, also wir hatten ja dann irgendwie
dieses nicht stattfindende Anbahnungsgespräch auf dem Camp. Das war wirklich lustig.
Es war wirklich schön.
Also wirklich ein tagelanger Versuch irgendwie ins Gespräch zu kommen. Und ähm ja, aber im Nachklapp äh hat es ja dann ganz gut funktioniert.
Jetzt müssen wir mal Thomas mal ein bisschen reinholen, weil gerade was so Podcasts betrifft, ähm wir haben uns ja auch über Podcast kreiert. Dann weißt du noch, wann das war, weil das muss ja auch in der Zeit gewesen sein
ähm früher sogar noch vor.
Also ich weiß irgendwie.
Wie du kanntest den Thomas von mir.
Ich glaube, also ich ich bin mal, ich bin mal, also wie bin ich zu Podcast gekommen? Ich habe irgendwie,
nach meinem Zivildienst einen ersten Entwicklerjob angenommen, der unheimlich langweilig war, aber Vollzeit, deswegen war ich ein ganz ein schlechter Mitarbeiter und ich habe damals auch irgendwie einen iPod geerbt
und habe halt angefangen, so auf iTunes herumzustöbern und bin auf
Chaosradio und Chaosradio Express gekommen und dann habe ich mitbekommen,
Es gibt so was wie eine Hackerszene und es gibt so was wie Hacker Spaces, da war ich dann auch sehr schnell,
und dann ja, war ich auch gleich irgendwie auf Konferenzen auf der Plumper Kon in Wien, das war glaube ich mein allererster Einstieg und dann war ich auf der Sick
in Köln, das war meine erste CCC-Veranstaltung, eben nicht der große Kongress und dort habe ich,
Tim kennen gelernt, ist ein Podcast, ich schon kannte. Markus Beckertal und Ralph Bendrath. Und das war irgendwie so das erste Andocken an diese Szene.
Wir haben uns auf der Sekunde kennengelernt.
Ja, zweitausendneun. Und dann war ich auf dem ersten Meeting,
Und da hast du mich übrigens ähm das erste Mal in die Meterebene geholt. Das war irgendwie eine äh persönliche Führung. Und auf jeden Fall habe ich dort auch Linus kennengelernt,
und äh ja, dann war irgendwie so ein interessanter Exchange, wo wir irgendwie draußen standen und so
Netzpolitik Org da bloggen und dann hatte ich auf einmal einen Autoren-Account und ziemlich bald darauf war ich dann auch in Lokbuchnetzpolitik. Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, welches Jahr das war, aber,
Das war so ungefähr der Einstieg.
Du warst gleich im März zwanzig zwölf, Folge siebzehn hier im Podcast. Äh hat auch nicht lange gedauert.
Krass, das hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht, dass das schon so früh war. Das gibt's ja nicht.
War zwanzig zehn, glaube ich, die erste oder zumindest ist das, was ich gerade finde, auf CCF Events CCC DE.
Eierkorde war zwei Punkt null, da erinnere ich mich doch, Daddy, genau, die erste zweitausend oder noch früher vielleicht sogar? Da war ich, glaube ich, auch.
Okay, das hatte ich jetzt gar nicht mehr so richtig aufm Zeiger. Das ist interessant, weil ähm ich weiß nur, dass wir uns in Wien auf diesem Hörer treffen, diesem sagenumwobenen äh wegweisenden Hörertreffen getroffen haben beim ersten Hörertreffen in Wien,
Da hast du nämlich mit deinem äh Podcast äh schon angefangen gehabt. Wie hieß der noch gleich?
Genau, ich äh ich habe äh zu meinem Anthropologie-Studium dann irgendwie den passenden Podcast gemacht mit Talking Entreupology dot com und da auch irgendwie vierzig Folgen äh rausgehauen,
und das war halt einfach es gab kein anthropologischen Podcast. Ich habe mir gedacht, das sind lauter spannende Themen von Menschen, die gerade von Feldforschung zurückkommen an Orten, wo bisher wenig Leute waren oder wenig Westler waren,
und ähm ja, das ist dann aber auch irgendwie in die Hacker-Szene abgedriftet, das ist jeder Klassiker, dieses going Native. Man man versucht in der Anthropologie immer mit einer Distanz, Dinge,
zu beforschen und dann fällt man in den Topf hinein und das Teil davon.
Genau, aber ich weiß deshalb noch so ganz genau, ähm davon, weil das war halt ein wichtiges Ding. Warte mal, das war das erste in Wien, das weiß ich sogar ganz genau, wann das war. Das war nämlich im April zwanzig zehn war das,
und da war ich da und dann äh haben wir uns da im Werkzeug H getroffen, da war auch der Georg da, der später dann auf Honig gegründet hat,
an dem Abend habe ich nämlich,
in seinem Beisein habe ich so extensiv mal meinen Leid geklagt und so nach dem Motto, es kann auch nicht sein, dass äh es nicht ein System gibt, wo Folgendes passiert und dann hat er mich irgendwie ein Jahr später angeschrieben und meint so, ja, läuft.
Österreicher Dieter Livern.
Das war das war wirklich grandios und und das hat dann wiederum äh in der Folge äh auch diese,
getriggert, dass ich dann gesagt habe, okay, jetzt gehen wir aber mit hier auch irgendwie all in so, ne. Ja, also das ist so ein bisschen die,
Genese kann man sagen, ne, wie wir alle so ein bisschen umeinander herumgetanzt sind, aber man kann das jetzt schon relativ klar festmachen so zweitausendneun bis zweitausendelf sind da die, die wichtigen Dinge passiert.
Ja.
Und danach war's eigentlich bis dass das.
Na ja, da ist da sind ja schon, also was äh was sich mit diesem Business as usual ähm insbesondere bei Thomas und Andre dann noch geändert hat, ist natürlich schon äh entscheidend.
Ähm Netzpolitik Org, Andre damals, du warst da noch der einzige Mitarbeiter, ne?
Ja ja, äh also jein äh neben Markus äh Markus war bei Netz Boutique org oder hat Netzpolitik auch gemacht,
Ich habe damals Netzpolitik auch gemacht, in der Theorie hätte ich auch noch Dinge für New Thinking machen sollen, äh aber das hat in der Praxis ähm nicht so gut geklappt und das habe ich,
auch nicht so sehr gewollt und dann irgendwann kam ich mit der Idee doch mittelfristig dieses Netzkritik Org aus diesem Netz äh aus diesem Newthinking rauszulösen.
Das hat ziemlich gut geklappt und vielleicht kann ich das auch mal verraten,
auf diesem Weg, habe ich mich dann auch äh relativ naiv so ein bisschen an Tim und der Meterebene orientiert mit,
Der kriegt ja nicht nur seine Bahnkarte hundert, sondern irgendwie sein Einkommen bezahlt von der Community, äh Werbe und Bullshit frei, äh dass er kostenlose Inhalte veröffentlicht. Warum sollte das bei Netzpolitik Org nicht auch klappen?
Ähm und dann haben wir das dort auch gemacht und mittlerweile ist das halt ein Laden mit äh einer knappen Million Jahresumsatz und fünfzehn Angestellten und.
Was im Wesentlichen aber auch auf der Basis dann läuft.
Ja ja äh wir sind äh Netz von ist fast ausschließlich äh Community finanziert. Es gibt
skurrilsten Dinge mit ab und zu spendet meine Firma was, aber ohne Gegenleistung und ohne Vertrag äh und das früher gab's immer Experimente mit Werbung, dass aber nie geklappt hat und auch eigentlich niemand so richtig will
und dann gibt's Dinge wie, wusstet ihr, dass wenn man vor Gericht,
kleinere Vergehen verurteilt wird und eine Geldstrafe zahlen muss, dass dieses Geld nicht automatisch an den Staat geht, sondern dass das an gemeinnützige Organisationen geben kann und
Gerichte haben Listen mit gemeinnützigen Organisationen, die sie dann verurteilten geben können mit du mussten tausend Strafe zahlen, such dir eine Organisation aus dieser Liste aus.
Das möchte ich auch, das möchte ich auch.
Sowas kommt bei uns auch ab und zu mal an.
Bist nicht gemeinnützig. Ach echt?
Wie kommt man, wie kommen wir auf die Liste?
Bei welchen Strafen? Bei.
Mir völlig egal.
So eine so eine Straftaten, von denen für die man vor Gericht für zu Geldstrafen verurteilt werden kann. Ich bin jetzt kein Jurist ähm aber das muss,
Meterebene ist, glaube ich, nicht gemeinnützig, aber das müssen dann, glaube ich, gemeinnützige Organisationen sein, weil der die Intention ist ja, dass die,
der eine Strafe zahlen, aber auch gleichzeitig einen Dienst an der Gemeinschaft tun und gemeinnütz,
Gemeinschaft. Äh das ist alles relativ nah. Jedenfalls war das nur als Beispiel gedacht für so kleinere Dinge, weswegen wir nicht hundert Prozent äh spendenfinanziert sind, aber so,
Extras gibt's dann immer mal noch.
Neunundneunzig Prozent Spenden und ein Prozent Strafen finanziert, ist doch eigentlich auch ein geiler.
Ich kann mich da noch ganz gut dran erinnern, dass Markus mich da auch angesprochen hatte. Äh ich glaube, es gab mal so ein Meeting bei,
Irgendwie, wo,
Zum Brainstorming gemacht wurde zu diesem Ganzen, was was muss man eigentlich tun, damit das irgendwie funktionieren kann, weil gab ja von Anfang an viel Zweifel da dran, so, ne? Und das äh kenne ich ja auch,
Auch ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass ich von Anfang an fest dran geglaubt habe, dass das geht. Es war mehr so ein, ich habe nicht unbedingt daran geglaubt, dass es nicht geht.
Ich weiß, dass du, dass du irgendwo bei CRE anfangst, mal gesagt hattest, so, ja, ich hätte gerne eine Bahnkarte, hundert, damit ich mehr podcasten kann.
Mit der Bahnkarte habe ich auch im Kopf, dass das so los.
Und dann habe ich gedacht so dreitausend waren wahrscheinlich noch Ostmark. Will der haben, der ist ja wahnsinnig.
Das war schon ein Schlüsselmoment mit dieser Bahncard. Und ich hatte, habe auch lange darüber nachgedacht. Also angefangen hat's ja dann wiederum mit der Republika, weil mir da mal mein Rechner geklaut wurde. Wir waren ja da bei dieser
bei der Party. Nee, nicht im Ruf, sondern äh auf der After-Party bei New Thinking.
Ach, da noch, ja.
Da ist irgendwie, da waren die Taschen im Hinterraum und da ist irgendeiner rein und hat sich irgendwie Taschen geklaut. So und das war dann halt irgendwie meine Tasche mit meinem Laptop und da war dann halt irgendwie, ne, klar, Laptop war irgendwie alles und da hatte ich irgendwie auch keine Reserven,
Und ich hatte zu dem Zeitpunkt schon mehrfach von Leuten, die haben, also mich hatten mehrfach schon Leute gefragt, ob sie mich äh, ob sie mir irgendwas spenden können,
Also das kam gar nicht mal von mir primär, sondern es kam erstmal von anderen Leuten. Ich habe halt immer gesagt, Leute, das ist hier alles total experimentell mit dieser ganzen Podcasterei. Ich weiß noch gar nicht, wohin das geht. Ähm lasst mal,
ich komme da vielleicht drauf zurück in dem Moment, wo ich euch auch ein konkretes Angebot machen kann, was dann dadurch eigentlich auch getragen werden soll.
Und dann kam halt
diese Klauerei und dann habe ich halt so einen Blogpost geschrieben, habe halt gesagt so, ja ähm gut, ein paar von euch hatten ja mal Spenden angeboten, jetzt wäre vielleicht mal ein ganz guter Zeitpunkt, weil ich jetzt irgendwie nicht so die äh Kohle hatte, um um das irgendwie auszugleichen.
Und dann ging das halt.
Sehr schnell so. Also es hat dann wirklich nicht lange gedauert und da war so diese Kohle für diesen Rechner wieder da. Dachte ich mir so, okay ähm,
das scheint ja wohl Leute irgendwie zu interessieren, weil äh das Interessante war für mich gar nicht so sehr, dass das Geld kam, sondern die Kommentare, die dabei standen
weil eigentlich so ein gefühlt neunzig Prozent der Leute sagten, damit's wieder Podcasts gibt
Und das war dann so für mich so so ein Aha-Moment, wo ich mir dachte, so okay, ähm scheint jetzt nicht so so schlecht angekommen zu sein. Und später habe ich das dann eben, dann habe ich halt drüber nachgedacht, okay,
keinen Bock hatte, einfach nur wie Klingelbeutel aufmachen und so weiter, ohne ohne eine konkrete konkretes Versprechen damit zu verbinden und dann habe ich halt gesagt, so, ja okay, äh was ist eigentlich der,
das Hauptproblem bei der Durchführung und es war halt, ich musste eben zu den Leuten hinfahren, weil damals war ja so Remote Podcast war ja nicht dran zu denken.
Heute schon.
Ist auch ist auch äh heute eigentlich immer noch eine scheiß Idee.
Vor Ort ist auch nicht immer einfach.
Also zumindest mit Leuten.
Ich kriege das eigentlich immer ganz gut hin, aber aus der Beta-Ebene.
Ähm auf jeden Fall war halt meine Ansage
was ihr mir ermöglichen könntet wäre eben zu reisen. Weil ich hatte einfach dieses Bedürfnis zu Reisen, aber es war halt jetzt auch nicht so denkbar, dass ich jetzt
was weiß ich, hunderte von Euro pro Woche ausgebe, um irgendwohin zu fahren, um mit Leuten zu sprechen und deswegen habe ich halt dieses Ding mit dieser Bahncard gemacht, was halt diesen Vorteil hatte, dass es eben so ein,
klar umrissen. Das Ziel war mit so einem klar, umrissenen Versprechen, so. Wenn BahnCard dann mehr reisen, dann mehr Podcast. Und das hat irgendwie wunderbar gezündet, diese Idee, die hat irgendwie jedem sofort eingeleuchtet offenbar.
Das ging dann halt auch äh relativ fix. Und das war dann auch so der Punkt, wo ich mir dachte, so,
Ich sollte aufhören, darüber nachzudenken, welche Businessmodelle ich jetzt hier irgendwie entwickeln muss, um in irgendeinem freien Markt äh zu arbeiten. Es ist eigentlich viel sinnvoller für eine Community,
zu arbeiten, weil die ja offensichtlich bereit ist, Dinge mitzutragen. Und,
Da kommt mir jetzt wieder zurück zu dieser Anfrage von Netzpolitik auch bei mir halt zu dem Zeitpunkt klar war, ja Leute, ihr macht genau das Gleiche wie ich auf eine andere Art und Weise und.
Das ist eigentlich gar nicht so schwierig. Ihr müsst nur darauf euch darauf konzentrieren ähm,
Die Personen und die Menschen, die dahinter stehen, auch ein bisschen mehr in den Vordergrund zu bringen. Also mich hat zum Beispiel gestört, dass bei den Blogposts nicht so ohne Weiteres immer ersichtlich war, wer hat die geschrieben so, ne, also dass man einfach auch die Person betreibt. Das ist sicherlich noch was zu verbessern, aber,
ist ein bisschen besser geworden. Ja und das abzuschließen,
hat ja dann auch funktioniert, weil die Leute einfach begreifen, dass sie eigentlich mit relativ wenig Unterstützung eine ganze Menge bewirken können,
Klar, so über fünf Euro im Monat für Netflix. Da macht man sich schon mal Gedanken drüber irgendwie. Komischerweise. Aber.
So den den Milchkaffee pro Monat ähm sein zu lassen, um so eine kulturelle Kraft zu unterstützen, die einem irgendwie eine ganze Menge,
gibt oder von der man meint, dass dass es sozusagen auch eine Driving Force ist in so einer Szene, dass,
leuchtet mehr Leuten ein, als man's vielleicht erstmal denken würde,
und deswegen klappt das mittlerweile gut und so Sachen wie und später Patreon zeigen, dass dass das tatsächlich eine eigene Ökonomie ist in gewisser Hinsicht, ne.
Ich habe mir herausgesucht, dass mit dem gestohlenen Laptop war zweitausendsieben.
April zweitausendsieben, ja.
Genau, äh muss man dazu sagen und äh November zweitausendachtzehn mit dann irgendwie ab Dezember der BahnCard und so war diese Bahncard Idee.
Ja, fand ich, fand ich auch äh spannend, diesen Rückblick. Äh ich habe auch noch gerade mal geguckt, April zwotausendsieben,
war grad CAE bei Folge vierundvierzig und das ist aber glaub ich auch 'ne Gemeinsamkeit all diese Projekte,
ich mein wir sind ohnehin relativ privilegiert, hier reden vier alte, weiße Männer die Telejobs haben in der im Westeuropa aber alle,
Unsere Projekte haben erst kostenlose Inhalte rausgehauen,
und sich danach dann dafür finanzieren lassen. Äh das ist jetzt nicht automatisch ein Businessmodel, wie die Welt da draußen normalerweise funktioniert. Das hätte ich aber gleich nochmal als Frage an Tim. Die ersten vierundvierzig Folgen
hast du quasi mit einer anderen Finanzierung gemacht, eh das mit den Spenden kam, das hast du als gemacht damals, oder? Weil also
Netzpolitik ORG, wir hatten erst die Querfinanzierung dieser Firma. Ich meine, Thomas hat auch jahrelang AK vor Ort Österreich vorher gemacht, ehrenamtlich,
Was hast du denn gemacht vor der Metaebene?
Ich habe,
also sagen wir mal so, ich ich lebe den Laster ja schon ein bisschen länger, weil ich habe ja ich kann mir neunundneunzig auf einmal äh in diese Rolle auf einmal so Event Heidi für den Club
zu sein. Da habe ich ja sogar, als ich, weil ich das Camp,
starten wollte, habe ich ja damals sogar meinen gut bezahlten Job äh gekündigt, weil mich das gelangweilt hat und,
Habe halt so von dem Geld, was ich damals hatte, äh erstmal irgendwie so weitergemacht und habe mich eigentlich über die Jahre nur durchs mein T-Shirt-Laden,
Hinterhemd äh über Wasser gehalten. Das war eigentlich so mein einziger Income, den ich hatte,
Und habe dann so erstmal so zehn Jahre diesen ganzen Clubkram gemacht und zweitausendsieben war dann so der große Change, wo ich auch alles übergeben hatte und wo ich dann gesagt habe, so macht ihr jetzt mal, ich habe das jetzt lang genug gemacht,
aber so Geld hatte ich da eigentlich keins. Also nie richtig, wirklich.
Und äh dann war's halt mit dem Podcast so, das das hat mich halt einfach total entflammt, also da bin ich halt einfach zweitausendfünf drauf gestoßen oder zweitausendvier, bin tatsächlich bin ich drauf gestoßen.
Und ich habe mich halt einfach zwei, drei Jahre damit beschäftigt und habe eigentlich nur so meine Reserven äh verbraucht,
hatte da noch ein bisschen Glück, weil ich in so einer Wohnung in Mitte wohnte, wo sie alle rausgeklagt haben und
durch 'ne geschickte Anwaltswahl ist mir gelungen da irgendwie dreißigtausend Euro rauszuziehen, so dass ich mich nochmal ein bisschen länger weiter verlängern konnte
und dann war aber schon klar, so perspektivisch irgendwas muss jetzt mal passieren und dann habe ich halt drüber nachgedacht. Es hat also gerade eben noch so,
so funktioniert, aber was du sagst, ist richtig. Diese Sachen funktionieren extrem gut, dadurch, dass man erstmal zeigt,
man eigentlich machen will. Und gerade wenn man das ohne Bezahlung macht, dann wirkt es natürlich auch gleich sehr viel glaubwürdiger. So, ja das ist wirklich das, was wir machen wollen, weil wir machen's nämlich sowieso schon. So, äh nur könnten wir es halt auch,
gibt's quasi sie jetzt so eine Versicherung durch euch, dass dass wir auch nicht so schnell wieder aufhören damit? So oder es vielleicht sogar noch, noch weiter steigern können. Und so so entstehen,
solche Projekte und das sind, glaube ich, würde ich dann auch die die Projekte, die so eine Sustainability eingebaut haben und gerade weil das so ist, weil die Leute wissen, dass es zwar schon davon abhängt, dass es Financial Support gibt, aber,
auch nicht unbedingt von vornherein, die Bedingungen dafür ist es, dass es überhaupt erstmal gab und das macht's dann eben auch nochmal doppelt,
glaubwürdig oder still so eine Verbindung äh her, weil ich habe.
Podcasting schon immer als so ein Community-Ding gesehen. Also immer als etwas, was man gar nicht so alleine macht, sondern es ist nur ich sitze halt hier äh in der Mitteebene und und orchestriere so einen sozialen Raum,
wo halt alle Hörerinnen und Hörer genauso dazugehören. Ich meine, ihr wisst ja, wie viel Feedback da kommt, wie viel, wie viel Rückmeldung man kriegt, wie viel
Lob oder eben auch Spender. Also es gibt ja verschiedenste Arten und Weisen, wie das so funktioniert und wie viel Leute sich dann über die Zeit auch aus dieser Szene heraus äh rekrutiert haben, als weitere äh,
Gäste, Projektpartner, Co-Moderatoren, et cetera. Wie wie Thomas zum Beispiel ja auch, ne?
Dein in den Kommentaren zu Logbuch ja auch gerne gescholtenen Hang zum Clubhaus,
einsortieren, ne? Das äh wir haben ja
durchaus bei Logbuch Netzpolitik sehr viel Kritik dafür bekommen, dass wir da auch äh mal zwei, drei Runden gemacht haben. Äh ich fand die Kritik auch berechtigt, weil sie kam halt von Leuten, für die der Einstieg in dieses Clubhaus zu dem Zeitpunkt
eine sehr hohe finanzielle Bürde gewesen wäre, nämlich die Anschaffung eines iOS-Devices so, ne, das ist äh das ist eine äh sehr hohe Pay
Äh gleichzeitig äh habe ich ja auch in den in den Gesprächen mit dir eben auch gemerkt, dass,
Dass das für dich halt sehr wichtig ist mit dieser Community zu sprechen. Und irgendwie über dieses Ding dienstags ist das ja immer mit Pavel zu dem UKW,
Da lässt sie ja nix draufkommen,
Da wird ja eher Logbuch Netzwerk verschoben, um anderthalb Stunden, weil das Studio nicht im Griff hast, als äh eine Klubhaus-Runde um eine Minute, ist ja fast wie Fußball bei dir. Vielleicht sogar noch wichtiger.
Interessanter Effekt. Ich meine gut, das hat natürlich auch ein bisschen was mit meiner Vergangenheit, mit der Villa äh zu tun in den neunziger Jahren
auch schon mal so ein System selber gebaut habe und deswegen gefiel mir Clubhaus nochmal extra, aber ich finde generell die ganze soziale Dynamik da ganz gut. Und diese Corona-Wikli-Sachen, weil da quatschen wir irgendwie in der Regel wirklich echt drei oder vier Stunden. Das ist nochmal länger als irgendwie der Podcast selber
aber da kommt so viel Energie äh zurück von den Leuten und man kann die so mit reinnehmen, dass das schon echt toll,
Müssen wir auf jeden Fall auch mal wieder machen. Haben wir jetzt ein bisschen schleifen lassen, weil,
die Sendung ist jetzt nicht so hergegeben haben oder wir Angst hatten, noch mehr über die Luca App reden zu müssen. Aber so grundsätzlich ist das, ist das schon cool, so ein interaktives Forum zu haben und,
Ich finde, Klubhaus ist da nach wie vor die beste Wahl. Ich meine, wie vorhergesagt, bauen ja jetzt alle dadran, sogar Spotify hat sich jetzt irgendwie so einen Club aus System irgendwie äh gebaut, Facebook,
bastelt noch an einem und so, aber das ist klar, ne? Weil das ist halt einfach eine mediale Spielart, die man irgendwie haben muss. Die werden nicht alle überleben, aber alle werden's zumindest mal ausprobieren. Mal gucken, wer übrig bleibt. Clubhaus wird wahrscheinlich übrig bleiben. Ein paar andere.
Ich wollte jetzt nicht so lange über Klubhaus reden. Ich wollte nur denn.
Ist so der Effekt.
Community Gedanken.
Zur Community gehören ja auch die Hörinnentreffen, von denen du ja vorhin gemeint hast, mehrere waren da ziemlich wegweisend,
waren aber eher so Meterebene höhere Innentreffen, weil die ist ja mit einer Person verbunden, das gab's für LNP jetzt nicht so, außer die Geburtstagspartys, oder?
Erinnere ich mich da falsch?
Nee, bei LNP waren's für dich mehr so die großen Events, die würde ich da mal so äh mit reinziehen.
Das hätte ich gerne anders gehabt, bin ich auch ehrlich. Aber ich mag auch, also der ist auch so ein,
also ich hätt's mir einerseits gewünscht, dass wir mehr LMP Hörertreffen machen oder Klein-Events oder Spontanen-Events, aber ich habe gleichzeitig auch von den Leuten gemerkt, wenn wir dann etwas kurzfristig ankündigen oder so oder das nur in Berlin ist
denn wirklich auch Beschwerden kommen, dass sie sagen, ey, König sowas bitte einen Monat vorher an, dann kann ich mir das Wochenende frei nehmen. Ich habe genug Überstunden,
und so, ne? Dann komme ich mal nach Berlin gefahren und,
Gleichzeitig sind das auch so Situationen, die mich regelmäßig so ein bisschen überfordern. Wenn dann da so viele Leute sind. Du weißt, die sind jetzt, kennen dich eigentlich alle und,
das ist also hat jetzt überhaupt nichts mit den Leuten zu tun, sondern einfach mit mir persönlich, dass ich mich dass ich dann einfach merke, dass mich das total stresst. Ja? Ähm.
Da habe ich jetzt, glaube ich, mit Tim, Linus und Thomas, drei Leute, die bestimmt schon mal irgendwie draußen beim Bahnfahren oder auf einer Party oder so von wildfremden Leuten angesprochen worden mit, ey, ich kenne dich doch aus,
Podcast aus Thomas, du machst viel Fernsehen, du machst extrem viel Medienarbeit äh oder Linus, ja du bist auch in jedem Monat mal in der Tagesschau,
Unter anderem eben durch diese kontinuierliche Arbeit hier.
Natürlich gibt's das, aber es gibt es nur hin und wieder, also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass du wirklich auf der Straße angesprochen wirst.
Teenager, Thomas, ja oder nein?
Nein, zum Glück nicht.
Die ganze Bahn, nicht die ganze Bahn.
Äh nee, es ist äh man wird schon hin und wieder angesprochen und ich ich freue mich eigentlich auch jedes Mal, gleichzeitig ähm,
Ja, ähm besten Fall ist es dann ein gutes Gespräch, wenn man mit diesen Menschen hat, wenn das so in der Summe
oder wenn da viele Leute sind, die eins zu eng ist, ja, viele Leute,
Glauben dich zu kennen oder haben erkennen dich an deiner Stimme. Das ist was beim, was bei mir am meisten ist, dass die Leute äh grade auf Veranstaltungen dann anhand der Stimme irgendwie,
einen zuordnen können und in Österreich ist es,
ähm ja, mittelbasig, ich ich habe das hin und wieder, dass dann Kellner von Restaurants irgendwie herkommen und ich habe dich da gesehen und so Sachen,
Ähm aber ja, also ich bin eigentlich sehr froh, dass das noch nicht überhand genommen hat, weil das ist natürlich auch,
ähm ja, Freiheit, Anonymität, das Freiheiten, das verlierst du an der Stelle, wenn du ähm,
überall dann irgendwie gleich auf die öffentliche Persönlichkeit zurückgeführt.
Sind wir so für Personalitätsschutz äh Datenschutz, persönliche Entwicklung und dann brauchen wir gar keine KI-Systeme und Kameras, sondern die Leute erkennen einfach an der Stimme, wer man ist.
Bei dir war das doch der der Höhepunkt äh zwanzig fünfzehn Landesverrat.
Landesvorrat ist eine ganze Weile her, aber das ja, da war einiges los.
Da weiß ich doch, dass du anfangen, dass du erzählst, dass du irgendwie im Restaurant die Rechnung nicht gekommen ist und solche Sachen, das weiß ich noch.
Äh ich habe vor Kurzem tatsächlich mal die äh LMP-Folge äh wieder angehört, weil ich dachte, ey, das ist irgendwie sechs Jahre her, äh wie war das damals eigentlich und du bist damals, wir hatten ja
Terror in der Redaktion mit, das war ein Medienanfragen und zu tun noch und nicht. Wir haben
mehrere Tage nicht so gut wie nicht geschlafen und nur Dinge gemacht und du bist dann einfach irgendwann aufgetaucht mit Bier und äh dem,
Headsets äh und ein Zoom-Aufnahmegerät und hast gesagt, so Leute,
Wir machen jetzt mal noch eine Stunde Podcast zwischen zwischen Tagesschau und was auch immer da noch war, äh war tatsächlich.
Das war ganz cool.
Tatsächlich eine ganz erhellende Folge, aber glücklicherweise hat sich sowas zumindest noch nicht in diesem Ausmaß,
wiederholt. Ich bin jetzt eigentlich eher Kamera und eigentlich auch Bühnenscheu. Äh es ist auch einer der Gründe,
warum ich nicht ganz so oft hier bin wie Thomas. Ich hab's Gefühl, du musst mich irgendwie zwei, drei Mal anfragen und so ein bisschen überreden äh bis ich dann irgendwann komme, bis ich das Gefühl habe,
ich habe auch was zu sagen,
einzubringen. Heute äh das eine war, dass ein Termin vorsteht und das andere war, dass ich dann die Frage habe, ja, was machen wir denn dann eigentlich? Was kann ich denn sagen, wie kann ich mich denn vorbereiten
manche andere Leute sind halt irgendeine natürliche und ach fällt schon was ein rauf auf die Bühne, das wird schon.
Ja, ja, Rampensau halt so, ne? Wobei Thomas jetzt auch nicht so die Rampensau ist. Bei dir ist ja eigentlich eh die Öffentlichkeit auch eher so so der Kompromiss zwischen dich will was erreichen, also muss ich mich auch ab und zu mal auf eine Aktionärsversammlung stellen.
Ja, ich bin ein schlechter Schauspieler, also ich, ich spiele mich eigentlich immer nur selbst. Und äh deswegen sind auch alles wirklich nur
Auftritte, Gallbitz Vorträge oder Kamera, wo es was zu sagen gibt und wo es einfach bei uns im Team immer die Diskussion ist, wer kann das jetzt am besten rüberbringen?
Und das ist auch einfach nur Übung und mit der Zeit verlierst du ähm einfach auch den Respekt davor. Du weißt,
wie du on gehst, wie du dich in diesen Zustand versetzt, dass du die richtige Rhetorik vor einer Kamera hast, das kennt Linus auch, ähm wenn du das erste Mal irgendwie so Hauptabendprogramm bist, dann,
ist das natürlich etwas, das die Respekt einjagt, aber dann ab dem zweiten, dritten, vierten Mal halt auch nicht mehr.
Das ist auch so ein CCC Ding, ne, also wenn man so im Club irgendwie wach wird, dann dann,
denn dann kriegst du das irgendwie eingeimpft. Das ist wirklich echt interessant, also das das das hat sich echt übertragen. Ich werde nie vergessen, das TCC hat ja mal,
diesen äh Preis bekommen bei der AS Electronicca Lins,
für quasi sein Lebenswerk. So also pauschal äh also wer es nicht kennt, als Elektroniker ist so der,
Kann man das sagen, so der Oskar, der, der, der New media Art
äh in Linz. Also wenn man den kriecht, so dann dann hat man's geschafft. Gut, der Club hat's vorher schon geschafft, aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen, das war, glaube ich, der Community-Preis oder irgendwie sowas. Auf jeden Fall haben die das beschlossen.
Ich find's schön, dass derjenige den Preis entgegengenommen hat. Er war irgendwie,
Computerpreise, das weiß ich jetzt auch nicht genau. Ich bin da, ich will noch mal hin.
Ich habe den angenommen, aber er ist selber ja nicht für mich, ja. Ich meine, er steht hier immer noch irgendwie da oben so,
Ja, ich habe mir gedacht, äh ich lasse ihn lieber bei mir stehen, als das aber im Club irgendwie wegkommt. Das ist hat,
hat noch nie einer gefragt, aber so zu gibt's das Ding zumindest noch. Sieht irgendwie ganz nett aus. Die Goldene Nica ist aber nicht so schwer, wie sie aussieht. Insofern.
Das Ding ist aus Plastik oder.
Das ist das ist Plastik und sie waren nicht klug genug, dazu müssen wir Blei reinzugießen oder irgendwas. Also es wirkt einfach überhaupt nullwertig. Das muss ich jetzt mal hier an der Stelle sagen.
Jemand irgendwie Augen, Löcher rein und macht so rote LEDs rein oder.
Irgend sowas, genau. Und das wollte ich halt verhindern. Auf jeden Fall gab's diesen Preis und wegen dieses Preises äh wurde dann ein äh Team, ein Fernsehteam, glaube ich, vom ORF beauftragt,
nach Berlin zu kommen in den Club um dort Material zu sammeln, damit sie eben am Ende,
auf der Veranstaltung so einen Trailer,
zeigen können mit hier der CCC und das ist der CCC und dann irgendwie so ein Fünf-Minuten-Ding oder so, also irgend so ein so eine Kurzversion von etwas Längerem, was dann später auch beim ORF quasi so als Dokumentation ist. Da müssen wir nochmal gucken, ob ob das,
online hast schon gefunden, okay, wie steht da, wie lang das ist?
Spontan nicht, aber es gibt ein Video. So äh dafür müsste ich jetzt irgendwie einen Flash-Player installieren, um.
Äh hat jetzt auf Adi.
Nicht gut geeitert.
Okay. Na ja auf jeden Fall,
kamen sie halt nach Berlin, um dieses Gespräch zu machen. Und es war dann halt irgendwie so eine Lady, die das irgendwie äh alles orchestriert hat und ich war quasi ihr Kontakt. Also es war so bisschen meine Aufgabe
dieses ganze Ding sollte ich halt abfeiern, weil ich war ja jetzt wegen war ich ja so der New Media Guy,
Und ähm ja, sie war ganz besorgt und so, ja, sie würde ja dann auch gerne mit Leuten sprechen und irgendwie, ob denn dann auch welche da wären und so, ja, kommt mal Dienstag rum, Dienstag war ja immer so unser Treffen,
Alles kein Problem. Und dann war das wirklich komisch, weil sie sie tauchten dann auf wie auf und es waren so,
aus dem Club, so ein, ich würde mal sagen, so achtzig Prozent der üblichen Verdächtigen waren damals dann halt auch immer dienstags irgendwie anwesend. Ihr wisst schon, in etwa, wen ich meine. Und,
Ich habe halt nur gesagt so, ja redet mal mit dem, dem, dem irgendwie, der der und der. Ja, dann müssen wir da irgendwas vorbereiten, nee, irgendwie,
Welche Fragen aus? Alles kein Problem.
Und ich habe denen erstmal irgendwie einen Text gegeben und dann ist er halt so reih um und hat irgendwie mit jedem dann im Club irgendwie, ich habe das auch gar nicht verfolgt. Nach einer Stunde waren sie irgendwie fertig. Kam so wie.
Nerven.
Nee, nee.
Weil sie nix rausschneiden konnten aus dem Stundesmaterial.
Genau, sie kam dann irgendwie auf mich zu und war so ein bisschen so fassungslos und meinte, also sie würde das ja jetzt auch schon eine Weile machen,
aber sowas hätte sie ja noch nie erlebt, ja, hier reden ja alle wie gedruckt. Ja, also hier kommt ja keiner aus der Spur, alle haben irgendwie
Text parat. Sie hat immer irgendwas gefragt und dann ohne, dass sie da irgendwie auch nur einen Schnitt oder einen zweiten Take mal ansetzen müssen, so. Alles gleich so fertig, sendefähig in der richtigen Diktion, in der richtigen Geschwindigkeit so beim ersten Mal,
saß, druckfrisch, kannte sie noch nicht, war total begeistert und irgendwie ist dann wieder abmarschiert nach einer Stunde.
Verschwenden halt ungern Zeit.
Ja, aber das ist auch so typisch Club irgendwie so. Also so typisch oder vielleicht auch so diese weitere Szene,
in der wir alle so eine Art Media Exposur haben, aber was ich halt auch sehr schätze, so kenne ich's halt auch aus dem Club,
Man weiß, man kennt seine Fakten, man weiß, was man vermitteln will, man man hat eine Strategie, wie man das macht. Man versteht auch die Sachen so gut,
dass man gar nicht groß um einen heißen Brei herumreden muss, wie das ja viele Leute machen, die eigentlich gar nicht genau wissen, wovon sie reden, deswegen reden sie auch so einen Quatsch.
Aber das ist halt äh hier äh nicht der Fall. Aber dann ist es einem auch irgendwo,
egal, also es gibt dann nicht so dieses so, ob ich den jetzt geil aussehe in der Tagesschau.
Deshalb Gelassenheit durch Kompetenz. Und äh es gibt aber auch eine andere Seite davon,
Diese andere Seite ist, das versuche ich immer, wenn wir die Sitze natürlich auch zwei Jahre lang nicht passiert, äh Pressetrainings im CCC machen zu sagen. Dazu gehört halt auch, dass du von den Dingen, von denen du keine Ahnung hast, halt auch nicht sprichst.
Genau. Wenn du keine Ahnung hast, einfach mal die Fresse halt.
Das ist jetzt ihr Zitat von jemandem, der den ich doof finde, aber ähm so insgesamt ist das, ne, es,
also willst du gelten, mach dich selten, rede halt nur von dem, was du sprichst und also das Zitat, was ich sehr viel schöner finde, ne, es ist besser zu schweigen und für einen Idioten gehalten zu werden, als den Mund aufzumachen und jeden Zweifel zu eliminieren.
Das war der Beste.
Das ist halt ähm,
der jetzt ist es natürlich auch so, dass du zweitausendzehn und auch auch noch zwanzig zwanzig und einundzwanzig mit Wissen über Technik sehr schnell kompetent wirkst, ähm weil sehr wenige es haben,
Würde aber nicht sagen, dass der Markt jetzt äh äh wenig Leute hat, die auch ohne Ahnung den Mund aufreißen. Und vor allem gibt's leider viele Leute, die halt dann auch den Unterschied nicht merken,
So und das ist der, das ist, glaube ich, also das halte ich für das Wichtigste.
Die senden oder von denen die äh von der Rezeption. Mhm.
Also äh beide, ne? Das ist also ich merke schon manchmal, dass äh wenn ich jetzt mit,
oder also in diesem Fall mache ich jetzt spezifisch Journalisten und Journalistinnen, äh dass die ähm mitunter,
sehr wenig von den Zusammenhängen, die ich darstelle, verstehen und auch verstehen wollen,
und ähm da musst du natürlich sehr vorsichtig sein und aufpassen, dass die dich am Ende korrekt wiedergeben. Dann nehme ich denen auch nicht übel, ne? Die haben auch ihre äh Constrance im Job und müssen,
Äh je nachdem für welches Medium sie unterwegs sind, zügig liefern ähm und so weiter und so fort, aber ich glaube, im CCC haben wir sehr darauf geachtet, dass halt,
wirklich niemals jemanden misstret und wenn das passiert, dass wir daraus äh die notwendigen ähm Konsequenzen ziehen,
Was bedeutet, äh das zu korrigieren, dem entgegen zu treten, mit den Leuten zu reden? Und das, das ist, glaube ich, tatsächlich das Wichtigste am CCC, dass da halt,
keiner den Mund aufmacht ohne Ahnung zu haben. Und wir haben genug Leute, die Ahnung haben, so dass wir zu allem was sagen können.
Gibt doch genug Leute, die Ahnung haben und trotzdem nehmen und nicht aufmachen. Also die äh
äh vielleicht, also nicht nur vielleicht, die richtig was auf dem Kasten nahmen, die vielleicht auch sprechtfähig werden, aber die trotzdem irgendwie diese Welt der Öffentlichkeit äh auch noch verknüpft mit äh meinem Name und oder Gesicht,
das liegt mir überhaupt nicht.
Und das finde ich andere, wenn ich dich ganz kurz unterbrechen darf, das finde ich total wichtig, dass du das ansprichst, weil nicht selten sind, dass die Leute, die mich halt sprechfähig überhaupt machen,
Ja, dass ich äh sage, okay pass auf, ich ich habe jetzt vier Stunden Zeit, mich vorzubereiten. Kannst du mir bitte das und das nochmal komplett im Detail erklären und die bereitwillig das tun, ob's CCC-Mitglieder sind oder nicht,
und nicht nur für was weiß ich CCC Pressearbeit, sondern natürlich auch für das Logbuch ist ja andauernd so, dass ich äh kann noch nicht mal sagen, wie viele Leute das sind,
die ich ähm regelmäßig oder die ich einmalig zu einem bestimmten Thema,
angerufen, angeschrieben oder sonst was haben und gesagt habe, pass auf, sag mal bitte hier dingens, ne? Und ich kann euch jetzt jedes Thema sagen, da wird bei jedem Thema gibt's irgendwelche ähm Hardcore-Nerds, die die mich dazu gebrieft haben. Auf jeden.
Alle denken, du wärst eigentlich so klug.
Na, ist es ja äh, das ist eigentlich auch, finde ich, einer der schönsten Aspekte des des Jobs, wenn Netzpolitik ein Job sein kann oder zumindest so wie wir ihn ausführen. Dieses Erarbeiten der eigenen Position.
Wenn du es in meinem Bereich sind häufig Gesetze oder irgendwelche technischen Vorhaben, die die auf einen zukommen und äh du hast Politik oder Medien, die Anfragen, du siehst, da ist etwas am Horizont, das,
Debatte beschäftigen wird und dann,
musst du dich mal einlesen, da musst du Gespräche führen, dann musst du ganz viele Abwägungen treffen. Und am Ende steht eine Positionierung.
Wurde halt auch klar sagen musst, ja, wo sind jetzt die,
Fallstricke, was sind die Gefahren, wenn das so kommt, wie es vorgeschlagen wurde? Ich habe das jetzt ganz konkret bei der Verordnung, ich weiß, wir reden jetzt nicht über Themen, aber elektronische Identität, darüber werde ich irgendwann später auch nochmal was hier sagen,
Aber das ist halt auch so ein super komplexes Thema und,
überhaupt da mal reinzukommen. Das war bei Contact-Tracing am Anfang der Fall. Central Dessentralized es beim grünen Pass, also das ist, was mich auch an wie bei der Stange hält
dass die Themen wechseln und es dadurch einfach nicht dienst nach Vorschrift ist, niemals sein kann. Viele der sonstigen,
Gaben sind eigentlich repetitiv äh Vorträge zu machen oder Policy Papers zu schreiben,
aber dieses sich wirklich in in die aktuellen Themen hineinzudenken und dann gestalterisch zu sein.
Und im besten Fall auch wirklich einen Unterschied machen zu können, das ist eigentlich die Motivation bei mir.
Ich finde das sehr spannend zwischen äh wie ihr jetzt schildert, äh dass es eigentlich bei uns ist, erst,
sich in dem Thema zu einzuarbeiten und dann darüber öffentlich zu sprechen,
und da draußen in der Welt äh habe ich nicht den Eindruck, dass das immer so ist ähm.
Eine seltene Tugend, ja.
Also früher haben wir uns äh über Internetausdrucker und lasst unser Internet in Ruhe, sonst nehmen wir euch die Fax-Geräte weg äh über die alte Generation lustig gemacht, irgendwie so in der Annahme
Ja, die sterben ja irgendwann aus und irgendwann werden alle Digital Natives, wir haben irgendwann
Broschüren gedruckt, wie das Internet funktioniert und haben die erst an aller Europaabgeordneten von Edri,
und dann auf Deutsch nochmal in alle Bundestagsabgeordneten von der geschickt aber irgendwie,
Pessimist, aber irgendwie glaube ich nicht mehr so wirklich daran, dass das Angebot,
Zu wissen, wie diese digitale Welt zumindest in Ansätzen in Grundlagen funktioniert,
Angenommen werden wird, selbst wenn es da ist, es werden immer noch Gesetze gemacht, es,
Grad letzte diese Woche, letzte Woche, wenn von Leuten, die tatsächlich über Themen reden, von denen sie offensichtlich keine Ahnung haben und die sprechen da im Bundestag drüber. Das,
überrascht mich.
Das Einzige, was sich, glaube ich, geändert hat, ist die Internetausdrucker drucken, das Internet nicht mehr aus. Ja, aber die haben die äh also die die lesen es jetzt auch am Bildschirm,
Aber so du hast schon recht, dass dieses fundamental Verständnis hat sich jetzt nicht in der Breite der Gesellschaft durchgesetzt. Ich halte das übrigens auch für eine Katastrophe
Und das ist auch einer der Gründe, also der wenn nicht überhaupt der Grund, warum ich diesen Podcast äh über ja bei ein paar Folgen war ich nicht dabei, aber sagen wir jetzt knapp vierhundert Folgen,
mache,
Weil ich glaube, dass das, was wir hier diskutieren, politische und technische Hintergründe nicht optionales Wissen für Bürgerinnen einer demokratischen Republik,
ist. Ähm in diesem Bereich. Also es wird es.
Nicht optional im Sinne von essentiell.
Essenziell, ja. Das ist nicht etwas, wo man sagen kann, ach so, die Nerds haben sich das mal angeguckt, die Nerds sagen, das und das ist ein Problem,
so, aber wie wie diese Diskussionen geführt werden. Wir sind ja äh von,
ich weiß selber, Andre, vor vor zehn Jahren haben wir dann da gesessen, haben gesagt, okay, die Internetausdrucker, die wissen gar nicht, was für einen Schaden die anrichten.
Ja? Diese Interpretation ist heute nicht mehr möglich, ne? Also wenn man jetzt über äh Staatssekretäre im Innenministerium redet, die wissen, welchen Schaden sie anrichten.
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion, wenn sie um den Staatstrojaner geht, nicht.
Die wissen's auch. Meinst du, die wissen es nicht.
Das gesagt, aber das kommt nicht im Hirn an.
Gut, aber ich meine, sie entscheiden ja auch bei Arbeitsmarktpolitik, Klima oder Verkehr auch nicht klüger. Also,
ja, Kompetenz und Bildung sind wichtiger Bestandteile, aber ich glaube, der wirkliche Gegner sind nicht die Leute, die es nicht verstanden haben, sondern gerade die Leute, die ein sehr gutes Verständnis von Technik haben, aber halten
ganz anderes Weltbild und deren Vision halt einfach staatstrojaner Sicherheitslücken scheißegal, wir müssen da reinschauen
Also das, das das sind am Ende Wertfragen für mich.
Das widerspricht sich nicht.
Beides ist äh richtig und beides ist wichtig. Also es gibt sowohl Leute, die die Gesetze schreiben und die im Innenministerium arbeiten, die das sehr wohl verstanden haben, ein anderes Weltbild haben, dann gibt's aber immer noch Leute im Bundestagsfraktion
die darüber abstimmen, die keine Ahnung haben, aber irgendwelche Sprech,
Zettel einfach blind vorlesen, ohne sich darüber eine eigene Meinung zu bilden. Also das schließt sich nicht aus, das ergänzt sich. Und beides ist extrem wichtig für die Debatte, das stimmt.
Ich möchte eigentlich gerade noch auf eine Frage antworten, die du äh,
vor zwanzig, dreißig Minuten gestellt hast, wo ich die ganze Zeit sage, da will ich auch noch was zu sagen. Bis das angespräch, angesprochen werden,
Da will ich nämlich total schlecht drin und meine Initialreaktion ist immer einfach zu leugnen, dass ich Linus Neumann wäre,
Das ist äh das ist äh so, ich war das nicht. Ja, das habe ich das habe ich einfach vor schon als äh Kind gelernt, wenn jemand dich nach deinem Namen fragt oder ob du irgendwas gemacht hast. Nein, das war ich nicht
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich weiß aber nicht, wer sie sind, ich komme von ganz woanders. Ich habe nicht mit dem Fußball ihre Küchenfensterscheibe eingekickt oder sowas, ja.
Ein bisschen schwierig mit deiner Frisur.
Ja mit der ja die,
gut.
Ich war nicht in der Tagesschau.
Es gab äh,
Und ich bin da sehr unelegant drin und ich glaube, dass ich da auch das schon viele Male echt ähm äh ziemlich abweisend und äh assi gewirkt habe, was nicht meine Absicht war. Ich erinnere mich an eine äh schöne Situation auf einem,
Musikfest, äh wo mich jemand ansprach, der war da so,
Kontrolleur mit nach Bändchen oder sowas. Und ähm,
sprach mich irgendwie an, ey sag mal, bist du Linus Normann? Ich so, nee, kenne ich nicht, keine Ahnung, tschüss, ne, bin weitergegangen und jetzt begab es sich aber, dass ich mit Tim da war und,
kam ich eine Stunde später mit Tim, durch die gleiche Kontrolle und Tim hatte ein LNP-Shirt an,
In äh in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern bei einem Musikfestival.
Ich erinnere mich.
Und ähm äh ich sagte dann nur so zu dem Typ so, nein, nein, nein, das ist nicht der von ich bin nicht.
Das war einer der wenigen Momente, wo ich die Situation wenigstens nochmal rennen konnte, weil ich der Person nochmal begegnet bin, ja. Aber ähm,
viele viele Male ist es tatsächlich einfach so, ne? Denn irgendwo sitzt du in der Bahn, hast passiert ja dann noch in ungünstigen Situationen, ne? Du, du stehst mit Kopfhörern in der Bahn, weil du die ganze Zeit telefonierst,
Grade ein Ohr abgekaut, deswegen merkt man nicht, dass du telefonierst und denkt, denkt, du würdest Musik hören, wirst dann angequatscht, ziehst den Nöppel raus, die Leute guckst, was wollen die, wollen die Geld? Ne, wollen sie nicht, also sagst du, nein und äh,
und nachher merkst du so Scheiße, das war eigentlich gerade in der Person, zu der hätte es da echt einfach mal ein nett sein können
und äh ja, also wer das hört, äh tut mir leid, ich werde diese Situation unbeholfen und ich arbeite an mir. Der Tim hilft mir dabei. Der Tim sagt, Linus, da musst du ganz einfach,
Nett sein und fragen, was sie so machen.
Ich denke, das ist extrem wichtig, dass man diese Balance hinbekommt und sich nicht irgendwie einbildet. Man will jetzt irgendwas verdammt irre Tolles. Nur weil man irgendwas macht, was was von vielen Leuten so asymmetrisch wahrgenommen wird. Ne, das.
Ich empfinde das als Last, diese asymmetrische Wahrnehmung. In meinen persönlichen Beziehungen.
Ja, es ist es ist ja, dass also, sagen wir mal so, ich kann nachvollziehen, dass man das als Last empfinden kann, aber man kann halt auch eine ein, ein Verhältnis dazu entwickeln, indem man das halt einfach als gegeben hinnimmt. Also ich,
kann damit umgehen. Ich ähm.
Ich merke schon, dass du es als gegeben hinnimmst, dass dich alle kennen.
Ne, der ist ja einfacher, es ist einfach ein ein ein Nebeneffekt, dass halt einfach, dass der nicht nicht vermeidbar so. Aber nur, weil ich jetzt in dieser Rolle als als,
oder als als Kommunikator von mehr Leuten gehört werde als ich höre,
Ist ja einfach nur eine eine Eigenschaft dessen, was ich tue, aber das sagt ja nichts über mich aus,
Ist halt die Rolle, die ich in dem Moment habe und ich denke halt, dass dass die Rolle der Zuhörenden in gewisser Hinsicht genauso wichtig ist,
und das levelt mich dann an an der Stelle auch gleich wieder aus. Also man soll sich halt da nicht groß was drauf einbilden, aber grundsätzlich ist es natürlich immer so,
aus Reichweite oder aus Bekanntheit,
oder Film oder auch wie immer das man nennen soll, erwächst halt auch 'ne Verantwortung. Gibt leider viele Leute, die dieser Verantwortung nicht gerecht werden, diesem ganzen Promi, in dieser ganzen Promi-Welt,
wimmelt es nur so von Leuten, die mit mit dieser Verantwortung nicht klar kommen. Ähm aber wenn man die akzeptiert, dann geht's eigentlich auch.
Ich glaube, es ist auch beruflich ist es auf jeden Fall eine Erleichterung. Also weil es öffnen sich Türen. Du kannst auf einmal Menschen an den Telefonhörer bekommen, die normalerweise ganz einfach nie mit dir sprechen würden,
privat ist es auf jeden Fall keine Erleichterung. Also zumindest hätte ich es noch nie so erlebt, dass es einem,
Glück zu finden irgendwie einfacher macht oder den Alltag einfacher macht,
es ganz spannender machen, einfach weil du mit mehr Menschen ins Gespräch kommst, ähm aber auch das ist keine Garantie.
Jetzt können wir ja mal vielleicht ein bisschen auf deine äh Arbeit auch nochmal gehen. Ähm Thomas, meine,
Ich habe dich kennengelernt, da warst du halt nur,
Das heißt nur, Wasser halt Podcast da. So, ne, da war dieses Tocking an, war so ein bisschen das das Feld, was so ausgekostet hat, aber da war ja diese Aktivistenrolle, die du dann geschlüpft bist, hat sich ja noch gar nicht abgezeichnet.
Was war denn da eigentlich bitte der Auslöser? Das habe ich noch nie so richtig verstanden?
Das war der elfte April zweitausendelf und sich.
Wieder zweitausendelf, da ist es schon wieder.
Ich war ja auf der Pressetribüne äh des Nationalrats in Österreich und das wurde die Vorratsdatenspeicherung beschlossen und,
dann an dem Abend habe ich eine Diskussionsveranstaltung zu dem Thema moderiert und das war so davor habe ich mich immer davor gesträubt, mich als Aktivist zu bezeichnen und und Aktivismus zu machen,
und da war's mehr oder weniger geschehen. Da ist es dann ein sehr.
Elfte April zweitausendelf.
Genau. Und dann bin ich beim, genau, Österreich. Und äh,
dann dann Ackervorrat und ein paar andere Vereine, auch die digitale Gesellschaft. Und dann ist das Ganze halt äh zweitausenddreizehn, vierzehnt vom Hobby zum Beruf geworden. Da ist eigentlich auch Linus dran Schuld dran.
Sorry, sorry.
Aber,
Ja, das äh das war ein Vortrag bei ähm einem CCC-Kongress, den eigentlich Markus Beckertal eingereicht hat, zu Netzneutalität,
und äh Markus wollte irgendwie nur über Deutschland reden und da war aber ein EU-Gesetz so eine Zentralität schon auf dem Horizont,
Also die Kommission hat's vorgestellt gehabt und dann meinte die uns irgendwie, ja du ihr müsst euch irgendwie den Stlog teilen, weil man muss da auch über Europa reden.
Moment, hattest du nicht auch Europa eingereicht?
Eingereicht hatte ich nicht, ich hätte mich nie getraut einen Congress-Talk einzureichen damals und dann war ich auf einmal auf der großen Bühne mit Becker und äh da war auch irgendwie Zugzwang und okay.
Habe ich dir nicht gesagt, du sollst einreichen, damit ich sagen kann, du hast eingerechnet, damit ich Markus sagen kann, wir müssen euch also irgendwie.
Was du erzählt hast, weiß ich nicht. Ich weiß, ich hätte's mich nicht getraut. Und dann war auch irgendwie so okay, Fakt, wir müssen dem Kongress was erzählen. Na gut, dann machen wir Safety Internet Punkt EU,
und haben dann halt irgendwie eine Kampagne gemacht und das war auch dann lustiger Abend, dass wir auf die Idee kam, Faxe zu verschicken ans Europaparlament,
Und dann ist halt die Kampagne entstanden, die bis zweitausendsechzehn das Thema getragen hat und weil der Talk äh scheinbar gut ankam, wurde ich dann von Iri noch auf dem Kongress gefragt, ob ich nicht irgendwie nach Brüssel gehen will und dort das Policy Advisor arbeiten und dann,
Habe ich halt irgendwie meinen Job gekündigt und bin nach Brüssel gegangen. Und dann, ja, kam ich zurück und habe ähm den Verein übernommen, der heute Epicenter Works ist.
Auch eigentlich schon von Anfang an mit dieser Idee.
Und Edri auch, ne?
Naja, ich bin, ich, ich habe damals bei Idri gearbeitet und dann dann war ich eigentlich nur wieder ja, halt Vertreter von einer Mitgliedsorganisation und im Vorstand von Edere bin ich erst seit, weiß nicht, zwei Jahren oder drei oder so,
ähm ja und halt auch ich ich finde auch in so NGO-Kontexten ist das mit Community finanziert der einzige saubere Weg diese Arbeit zu machen,
Also es gibt doch wahnsinnig gute Arbeit, die von Stiftungen und so finanziert ist, aber ich glaube, du hast halt nur, wenn die Community dir überhaupt ermöglicht, das zu tun, was du tust, das richtige Anreizsystem und den richtigen Fokus.
Ähm und zumindest für diese reaktive Arbeit, die versucht, der Politik gegenüber zu sein und ein Wortstock zu sein,
hilft es eigentlich, wenn das, was auch ähm ja, die Interessen der Bevölkerung sind, die ja der Auftrag ist.
Du hast ja,
eigentlich ein ganz gut, also meine ich zumindest, einen ganz guten Blick, sowohl auf die Österreicher, österreichische als auch auf die deutsche Situation, also nicht die politische Situation, sondern auch diese Community-Situation.
Gibt's da eigentlich Unterschiede oder würdest du sagen, das ist eigentlich Sam Same by Different?
Markus Gropische Vergleiche sind immer schwierig, also in Deutschland ist die Debatte,
älter. Es gibt mehr Organisationen. Es fällt mir von außen sehr schwer, dass jetzt irgendwie zu bewerten oder miteinander zu vergleichen,
Ähm ich frage mich irgendwie so, wer, wer für die Politik der Ansprechpartner ist oder der Stachel im Arsch, der die Dinge sagt, die wehtun, wenn Blödsinn passiert,
ähm und es gibt auf jeden Fall irgendwie diese mediale Begleitung, aber es ist ja auch ganz viel Network im Parlament, Leute zu überzeugen,
und da weiß ich aber, kenne ich vielleicht auch den Bundestag nur nicht gut genug, das kann andere vielleicht besser sagen, aber das ist, was das ähm hat für uns einen großen Teil der Arbeit ausmacht, diese klassische Advocy.
Meinte jetzt gar nicht so sehr die Politikseite, sondern mehr die Community Seite.
Naja, ich meine, der CCC ist der kulturelle Hab der netzpolitischen Community.
Und zwar nicht nur im deutschsprachigen Raum, sondern äh auch in vielen anderen europäischen Ländern,
das fehlt natürlich in der Form. Also ich meine, es gibt die As Elektroniker, es wird das lustig gefunden, dass du die vorher erwähntest, weil ich war, hatte heute einen einen Anruf mit denen und äh wir wollen kooperieren dieses Jahr, die ist ja wieder am achten September in Linz,
Und ähm es hat aber irgendwie doch jetzt viele Jahre gedauert, bis wir auf die Idee kamen,
ähm dass das eigentlich zusammengehört. Also ich glaube, grad diese Verschmelzung von der klassischen Netzpolitik mit,
der Kultur, der Technoszene, der Kunstszene, das ist,
Dass es in Deutschland schon wirklich vorbildlich gelungen. Und ich glaube, das strahlt in ganz viele andere Bereiche hinein und ist ein positiver,
Anstoß für viele Dinge, die man vielleicht so auch gar nicht mitbekommt. Also ähm das das ist
auf jeden Fall ähm einer der größten Unterschiede. Also immer wenn wir was in Brüssel gewonnen haben, am liebsten wär's mir, wir würden die Party in Berlin machen, weil ähm da ist nicht nur die beste Party, sondern da sind auch die Leute, die am ersten verstehen, worum es hier eigentlich geht,
und ähm deswegen ist es auch, glaube ich, für auch viele Leute von anderen NGOs ähm so ein bissel ein Zuhause.
Das ist interessant, dass du das so irgendwie auf den wieder auf den Club zurückführst,
Irgendwas ist da, irgendwas ist da zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt passiert, was irgendwie ganz gut gelaufen ist. Habe ich so den Eindruck.
Da standen beim CCC nicht immer alle Sterne nach. Aber manchmal.
Nee, ist schon ein paar Sachen waren schon echt gut.
Ich möchte nochmal eine Sache ansprechen Andre und das ist dann schon dieser Wandel von Netzpolitik Org. Also diese diese Darstellung kaum war der Dinos weg, haben wir eine Millionen Umsatz gemacht. Die passen mir noch nicht.
Das hast du jetzt rausgehört.
Also es gibt,
Also ohne da jetzt äh wenn wir ohne da jetzt oft das ganze Medium zu schauen, du kannst selbstverständlich nicht für für fünfzehn Leute, die bei Netzbild org arbeiten und die da auch mit seit unterschiedlichen Zeiten äh Markus Beckedal, seit
Zweitausendvier, glaube ich, ne? Oder war da oder seit seit wann gibt's nichts mit Tick org?
Ja, so Pi mal Daumen.
Der Markus, da seit so vielen Jahren äh viele Leute, die wir kennen, viele Leute auch mit großen äh Namen in der im Bereich des Journalismus inzwischen dort oder dort gewesen. Ähm aber nur deine Entwicklung,
ähm du warst in meiner Wahrnehmung jetzt nie ähm,
so ein Drauf-Trash-Journalist, sondern eher so ein so ein richtig tiefboard Journalist und dann dann sprudelt da das Öl raus. Habe ich das
Und wie gesagt, geht jetzt nicht um um viele andere bei Netzpolitik, Ork, die selbstverständlich unterschiedlich arbeiten ist, auch genau richtig und gut und wichtig, so, dass man das in einer Redaktion so macht, aber erzähl doch mal bitte von deiner,
ähm,
Motivation an diesen Themen so ewig lange dran zu bleiben, weil das ist echt etwas, was ich bei investigativen Journalisten ich persönlich,
nicht verstehe, wie man mit so einer, also so langfristig ohne klare Aussicht auf Erfolg,
An so einem Thema dranbleibt und sich da reinnördet. Ich äh ich äh ich vergleiche das so ein bisschen mit ihr meiner normalen Tätigkeit irgendwie IT-Sicherheitslücken finden. Da weiß man auch nie, ob man am Ende einen Erfolg hat. Ist das vergleichbar äh investigativer Journalismus?
Die kurze Antwort ist, ja, es wird ein bisschen ausfallen wollen, denn das mit der Million kann ich natürlich nicht so stehen lassen, als ob das irgendwie Korrelation oder Kausalität mit dir gewesen wäre,
ähm Netzpolitik Ork war ja lange das
Nebenprojekt von Markus Beckedal ähm neben seinem eigentlichen Dayjob von der Firma, die er mit gegründet hat, New Thinking, die da so Haufen, Tech, Open Source auch und dann irgendwann Veranstaltungsdinger, sind ja auch die Republica gewachsen ist
gemacht hatte. Das war am Anfang, wie war die Beiline Backpacking to World Politics, als er irgendwie zum World Summit of Information Society gefahren ist, ähm.
Tunesien.
Ja genau, äh so eine IT, Internet Governance Forum, äh Aktivitäten, so die ganz großen internationalen Netzpolitik vor, die wir auch nicht immer gut genug aufm Schirm haben,
ähm bis es dann zu dem Punkt kam, an dem Markus neben seinem,
quasi neben der Arbeit ähm,
vollgeblockten ähm Internet, äh sowas anderes als einen Newsletter mit einem anderen Format, im Web halt,
auch noch Leute einstellen konnte als dich und mich hat's ja auch viele Jahre gedauert,
Dann hat's auch nochmal eine ganze Weile gedauert, nachdem ich da war. Ich weiß gar nicht, äh wann wir in den Verein gegründet haben. Zwanzig dreizehn oder zwanzig vierzehn, dann haben wir überhaupt.
Lange Zeit synonym Markus Beckerdal und Netzpolitik, das war.
Teilweise immer noch. Weißt du, was auch synonym ist, was viele E-Mails wir kriegen mit, ich habe einen Podcast gehört, die meinen eigenen Lockbuchnetz-Politik, das kriegt ihr doch garantiert.
Uns nicht eine weitergeleitet. Habt ihr uns nicht eine.
Sollen wir das mal machen? Kommt einmal im Monat. Äh also das mit der Namensgebung äh ist.
Sorry, es tut mir leid.
Ist
äh immerhin habe ich jetzt erfahren, wofür das Logbuch, wo das Logbuch eigentlich herkam und dass das eigentlich mal anders gedacht war und irgendwie nur so ein bisschen überschüssig da dranhängen. Aber irgendwann haben wir einen Verein gegründet, aber nicht um dem Grund, weil wir eine juristische Person brauchen äh oder wollen, ja, sondern einfach nur,
Wir wollen Spenden wieder Tim, also brauchen wir ein Konto, aber das wollten weder Markus und ich auf unseren Namen machen, also haben wir halt einen Verein gegründet.
Hat aber gut funktioniert, jetzt kriegt ihr mehr Spender als der Tim.
Funktioniert und ja mittlerweile sind wir auch mehr Leute und äh in Textform ist es halt möglich, ein paar mehr Inhalte zu äh veröffentlichen und zu produzieren äh als.
Faul.
Eigentlich, das kommt auch nochmal dazu, als in eigentlich wöchentlich geplanten äh Audio. Ähm.
Ja, also das ist so, ich würde sagen, es ist hat so ein lineares Wachstum hingelegt, Netzpolitik, org, zumindest seit der Zeit, wo ich da war, auch ein Landesverrat hat übrigens nur zu einem kurzen Peak an Spenden geführt und nicht zu einer dauerhaften
äh Vervielfältigung,
skurriler Weise so gefühlt habe ich jetzt nicht alle Daten komplett im Kopf, aber halt Netzpolitik seit der Vereinsgründung, seit der Gründung mit den Spenden so ein lineares Wachstum hingelegt mit all den Vor-und Nachteilen,
Ich habe mir vor allen in den letzten Jahren aber lustigerweise ähm auch in den Anfängen,
Freiheit genommen, so,
Themen auch mal gründlich zu bearbeiten, also Blogging, dieses, wo kommt dann das her, irgendwie mit den Nuller oder so? Wohin haben wir gescherzt, das erste Block, was ich gelesen habe, war tausend Wege, ein Bier zu öffnen, so so,
zwotausenddrei, vier, fünf, sechs, dieses Blog war einfach, man,
hat irgendeine Idee, man schnappt irgendwas auf, man kommentiert irgendwas und haut das fix raus. Äh gab's damals noch gar nicht. Und auch ich habe an den Anfangszeiten bei Netzpolitik das passiert,
dazu oder überhaupt nur Information von das ist grade los gemacht aber eigentlich hat mich
Weiß gar nicht, das könntest du als Psychologe sagen, vielleicht meine persönliche Veranlagung mehr interessiert, immer tiefer zu graben. Wo kommt denn das eigentlich her.
Und eine der vielen Experimente, die wir bei Netzpolitik Org haben, waren, dann gab's damals 'n erst,
die und dann studentischen Mitarbeiter oder so, der noch bei der jetzt war, der Videos mit uns gemacht hat, ähm Videointerviews zu, wie sehen wir uns eigentlich unsere Arbeit und spendet für Netzpolitik ORG,
der Andreas und der hat mich damals, das ist ein grauenhaftes Video, ist eigentlich schäme ich mich, das zu erwähnen, weil es jetzt Leute nachgucken werden. Nein, du tust das nicht,
Tunels. Äh aber da habe ich gesagt, also eigentlich treibt mich an, wenn's in der Politik oder in irgendeine Berichterstattung ein Dokument erwähnt wird.
Da sehe ich das.
Dann will ich das auch haben, dann will ich nicht einfach nur lesen, liegt uns vor oder wo du draus zitiert oder wird darüber diskutiert, denn wie kann ich denn, ich komme aus dem Internet? Wie kann ich denn worüber diskutieren?
Wenn ich nicht auch die Originalquelle dazu habe. Ich meine, dann kamen viele Dinge parallel. Wiki Leaks ist damals groß geworden, aber überhaupt dieses Ding.
Eines Links, eines Webs von wir haben die Wahrheit nicht gepachtet. Hier ist unsere kleine Parzelle in dieser weltweiten Vernetzung, äh aber es gibt überhaupt keinen Grund mehr original Dokumente zurückzuhalten. Es genug,
im Internet, genug Platz auf unserem Server. Äh und mich hat das schon immer angetrieben,
nicht nur den Dokumenten, sondern auch bei anderen Fragen, wenn ich eine Frage habe, die ich mir stelle aus der Berichterstattung hinterherzufragen, warum ist das eigentlich so? Woher kommt das? Immer noch.
Weiterzugehen. Ähm das muss man sich leisten können, äh das kann sich Netzpolitik leisten. Äh man muss um,
dafür haben, tatsächlich wie du sagst, ähm es sind auch viele, viele, viele Fragen, die ich versucht habe, zu beantworten, wo die Antwort dann entweder nicht erreichbar oder extrem banal war, äh die einfach nicht berichtenswert waren,
aber immer mal wieder gibt's dann halt ähm eine Antwort auf die man stößt, wo man denkt, ui das ist ein bisschen anders als bisher, äh berichterstattet. Äh,
oder überhaupt bekannt oder ist es vielleicht sogar irgendein Kracher drin und keine Ahnung, äh irgend,
oder hat 'ne gute Abwägung die wir einfach so nie treffen würden,
und das konnte ich ja eigentlich in den ersten, ich mein ich hab angefangen zwanzig zwölf bei Netzpolitik ORG,
Verrat war zwanzig fünfzehn, da kam auch noch viel zu äh zusammen. Wir haben viel über zwanzig elf geredet, aber zwanzig dreizehn war natürlich snowden, ja. Das war auch für unsere ganze.
Ja, okay. Naja.
Szene für die Podcast-Landschaft für Logbuchnetzpolitik aber auch für Netzpolitik ORG sehr zentral, dann kommt dieser Untersuchungsausschuss, den wir begleitet haben,
und dann ging eigentlich Hand in Hand so 'ne glückliche Fügung der Geschichte, so 'ne Entwicklung, dass wir halt immer mehr eigene journalistische Arbeit gemacht haben, die von dem klassischen,
So Ronny, Kraftfuttermischwerk, hier lustiges Video, hier Gesetzentwurf, hier Spiegelartikel, hier heiße Artikel äh hinausgeht,
und was eigenes beiträgt dazu und mittlerweile ist Netzpolitik auch halt ganz klar journalistisches Projekt alle Presseausweise Journalistenpreise halten,
schon bei Landesverrat, weil dieser Trupps eigentlich.
Aber ihr habt ja auch dem Journalismus auch einiges Neues gegeben, ne. Also so was wie diese diese Begleitung bei diesem äh Ausschuss äh dieses permanente Bloggen, ne, wo so Berichts, wie war das nochmal? Da war so Bericht.
Andre aber schon das ist nämlich glaube ich übrigens,
ich weiß nicht, ob du das anders erinnerst, aber das war, wo wir uns mal kennen, also wo wir uns wirklich so offiziell kennengelernt haben. Wir wussten, äh ich wusste, es gibt dich, du wusstest, es gibt mich. Wir sind uns vielleicht auch mal irgendwo über den Weg gelaufen, aber es gab,
Ich kann ja nichts, nicht mehr sagen, was das war. Es gab eine Anhörung in einem Ausschuss im Deutschen Bundestag. Da saß der, ich glaube, da saß der Zirke damals noch BKA-Chef
Und da waren wir beide zum live Bloggen. Ich weiß, ich glaube, ich war nur da, um sie mir anzuhören, du zum Livebloggen, wie aber auch immer, aber das war so, da kamst du rein, da haben wir uns so irgendwie so,
Andre, minus zack, Hand gegeben. Das ist so meine Erinnerung. Das war wahrscheinlich zwanzig zehn oder so. Ähm,
diese live, also in den Anhörungen sitzen und sich die anhören und daraus bloggen oder live bloggen, das gab's damals schon, das ist natürlich dann mit dem Untersuchungsausschuss noch sehr viel größer geworden und das war ähm.
Eine der vielen Male, das Netz für Tick Org, sich zur Primärquelle gemacht hat,
Und auch mit deinen investigativen Arbeiten ist das ja so. Du hast da ein bisschen, finde ich, erkenne ich, dass du ähnlich äh arbeitest, äh nach einem ähnlichen Konzept wie Intersep,
die Dokumente vollständig gelesen haben, inhaltliche Zusammenfassungen machen, O-Töne dazu sammeln und im Prinzip so eine fertige Pressemappe für andere bereitstellen, die dann die kürzeren Artikel gerne schreiben dürfen,
So habe ich ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass das oft dein dein Arbeitsergebnis ist.
Ja, also,
Wir haben nicht alles erfunden. Äh sowohl investigative Recherche gab's woanders als zu dieser Zeit war Wikilix ziemlich präsent, so zwotausendneun, zehn, elf, da haben wir uns natürlich auch viel abgeguckt und viel weiter gemacht und eigentlich kommt man ja aus dem selben Sumpf. Da ging's auch weniger
welches Label draufklebt, sondern welche Arbeit äh das die Arbeit halt gemacht wird,
das mit dem ist interessant, dass du dich erinnerst, das war bestimmt 'ne Anhörung zwotausendneun oder zehn im BKA-Gesetz damals im Bundestag,
Ja, da habe ich live geblockt. Aber ich habe das von Matthias Schindler, ähm der, ich weiß nicht, den hattet ihr, glaube ich, noch nicht in der Sendung, weil.
Aber mal.
Müssen wir mal holen, der insbesondere bei der.
Stein.
Szene vor allem große Rolle spielt.
Viel Wikipedia gemacht, äh der hat zwischendurch, der hat erst bei Julia Reeder als im Büro gearbeitet, dann hat er bei Anke Domstedt Börk im Büro gearbeitet, jetzt arbeitet er bei Maria Schäffer, äh Grüne in Brandenburg im Büro,
der hat vorher Policy Arbeit bei Wikipedia gemacht. Der hatte damals äh in der Bundestagsanhörung zum Leistungsschutzrecht, das mit dem Live-Blogging erfunden äh und im Titel vom Wordpress,
dass I mit dem O die auch direkt nebeneinander in der Tastatur sind verwechselt und Love Blogging draus gemacht,
das war irgendwie ein kurzer Hashtag äh ein Lacher und das Konzept zumindest in meiner Erinnerung, wo ich das her habe,
ähm wurde da zumindest geboren und ich habe das dann noch weiter gemacht. Also wir haben auch nicht nicht alles erfunden.
Ich also erfunden hat man am Ende wahrscheinlich kaum etwas, aber geprägt auf jeden Fall.
Also für, ich würde sagen, für den Journalismus war das damals schon, also ich rede ja jetzt nicht, ich rede ja nicht von dieser Staats
Trojanergeschicht, sondern ich rede von einem NSA-Ausschuss, ne? Das da war das, glaube ich, am aktivsten. Also haben sichtbaresten. Da war das sozusagen dieses
Team, irgendeiner sitzt da immer und äh der Start versucht alles um in irgendeiner Form diese Berichterstattung zu hemmen,
und ihr habt das einfach komplett unterlaufen durch euer.
Das war damals schon relativ prägend dieses Konzeptuntersuchungsausschuss, man darf die Öffentlichkeit darf teilnehmen, man darf sich in den Saal setzen,
aber die Protokolle die werden nicht veröffentlicht von dem was da gesagt wird das gibt's dann erst zum Ende der Beweisaufnahme aber es kann sich halt jeder reinsetzen
streamen ist verboten, Fotos sind verboten, aber in der Tastatur eingeben äh und dann immer mal wieder Update zu klicken, dass wir nicht verboten, wobei,
Das war auch extrem umstritten, die haben das intern besprochen, ob man es zulassen kann oder nicht. Die Mehrheitsverhältnisse waren zu unseren Gunsten, aber dann hatte ich noch einen Cop hinter mir, so von der Bundestagspolizei. Ähm,
die da auch gedacht haben, irgendwie ist dieses neue Ding so zu skurril und das ist nicht die klassische Art von Journalismus, die wir kennen und mit der wir umgehen können,
Also da haben wir schon versucht, so ein bisschen das Spielfeld zu erweitern. Ja.
Gab noch, glaube ich, einen anderen, eine andere Sache, die sie nicht verbieten konnten, das war das äh Aquarell-Zeichnen.
Consteller.
War dann die, das nächste Level, genau. Die Zeugen dürfen nicht fotografiert werden, aber gegen Zeichnen hat niemand was gesagt. Wie bei Gerichtsverfahren.
Genau, die dann die Aquarellzeichnung immer veröffentlicht hat für den äh technische Aufklärung Podcast.
Immer noch. Äh es gab ja auch dieses äh diese
Legislaturperiode vier, äh Untersuchungsausschüsse, Untersuchungsausschuss eins war Breitscheidplatz, Attentat, wo auch Stella
und Daniel drin saß auch ein Podcast dazu gemacht haben und sie auch die Zeugen gezeichnet haben und wo auch Feedback kamen mit und jene Zeugin, also bitte, bitte, bitte, da
können wir eigentlich nicht, dass die auch nur gezeichnet werden, weil die sind super geheimer V-Mannführer beim Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz oder was auch immer,
und dann haben sie eben wegen Stella die Sitzung anders eingestuft und in den Raum ohne Öffentlichkeit gemacht oder so.
Und äh was ja zwischendurch auch noch gemacht hat, war die Leute aus zu kneten. Weil ihr von den Zeichnen langweilig wurde. Das ist schon schon ganz geil.
Audio.
Audio Podcast ins Internet schreiben zu zeichnen und Leute in 3D zu kneten. Aha. Multimedia.
Das ist wirklich Multimedia.
So Leute, das war jetzt ganz viel Vergangenheit.
Du willst jetzt hier du wegen dieses Fußballspiels.
Ich habe noch ein bissel Zug.
Also ja, genau, jetzt ich wollte auf die Zukunft äh kommen. Jetzt müssen wir, verstehst du, jeder gute Podcast braucht einfach auch eine Storyline. Und,
kann abstrakt sein, aber sie muss da sein, damit damit irgendwie damit auch alle mitgehen können. Jetzt haben wir auch viel über alte Zeiten geredet. Jetzt ist die Frage, was passiert, wo geht's hin? Dein Einsatz, Thomas.
Mein Gott, ich wollte mich selbst machen und sagen.
Du hast was gesagt, ja.
Jana, ich habe ich habe in der Pandemie ein Theaterstück geschrieben und das hat jetzt dann am im Juli seine Premiere und da wollte ich nur.
Oho. Ernsthaft?
Hast du nicht genug zu tun?
In Österreich kein, äh habt ihr in Österreich keine politischen Skandale oder.
Nie, niemals.
Äh billiger komplett Unbeteiligt,
Nein, der Pandemie wollen wir langweilig und ja, Kontrolle ist gut, eine Mitmachdystophie, gibt's vier Spieltermine im Kultursommer und beginnt am dreiundzwanzigsten Juli,
es ist ein Experiment, es soll lustig sein, also man kann sich's vielleicht anschauen,
und ist halt auch der Versuch, mal Netzpolitik zu vermitteln, auf eine andere Art. Und äh ja.
Das finde ich jetzt wirklich mal echt interessant, weil ich meine, du hast ja vorhin schon gelobt, dass es sozusagen der Szene über die Jahrzehnte gelungen ist, diese,
diesen Brückenschlag der Kulturen zu äh ermöglichen, ne? Weil ich glaube, das ist auch eine eine Form des des äh der Selbstermächtigung ist, dass man,
akzeptiert und realisiert, dass die eigene Willenskraft äh und der die eigene Szene, die damit verbunden ist, unter Umständen nicht ausreicht, aber sie,
Eigentlich in ähnlicher Form auch in anderen Szenen auch vorhanden ist. Ne, was für Beispiele genannt, Techno-Szene so, also sozusagen so dieses
raus aus den alten Feierkultur et cetera, Kunstkultur, Ausdruck, einfach auch persönliche
sich selbst auch vergewissern, dass man auch jenseits des Mainstreams eine eine Identität hat. Das sind so Sachen, die da mit drinstecken,
Theater finde ich jetzt wiederum ist so ein Bereich, den wir, glaube ich, noch gar nicht so unbedingt erreicht haben. Und ich persönlich habe auch so ein bisschen so ein, so einen, so eine, so ein, so eine Theater,
Phobie würde jetzt so ein bisschen aber ich bin, ich bin so ein bisschen Theateragenostisch, ich kann nicht so richtig was damit anfangen, aber ich akzeptiere und weiß auch, dass.
Dass es das gibt.
Nicht nur, dass es das gibt, sondern dass das Theater an sich, wenn es gut und richtig gemacht ist und das gibt's ja auch. Dass das Gruppen sind,
die sich eigentlich auf eine ähnliche Art und Weise mit der Zukunft beschäftigen,
Wir machen das so aus so einer technischen Expertise heraus. Wir wir lesen so die Zeichen, wir wissen, wohin das führt, wir wissen, was dadurch ermöglicht wird und daraus leiten wir unsere Zukunftsvorhersage ab,
Im Theater ist es so
Das ist eher eine aktive Begleitung des sozialen Geschehens ist. Das sind Leute, die sind wach in der Gesellschaft, die nehmen Strömung, die nehmen Tendenzen auf und ein gutes Theaterstück fällt dadurch auf, dass es im Prinzip,
Zukunft der nächsten fünf Jahre vielleicht nicht vorhersagt aber zumindest ein Bild zeichnet von dem wo es hingehen könnte und da,
abliefert und und und an Moral und Ethik und was nicht alles äh appelliert durch die Arbeit. Das das ist so meine Wahrnehmung,
Guten Theater.
Ein gutes Theaterstück geschrieben.
Das ist die andere Frage, ja. Aber worauf ich eigentlich hinaus wollte, ist so dieses,
der Aufbruch, den wir, glaube ich, nie aufhören dürfen, voranzutreiben,
ist eigentlich nicht zufrieden zu sein mit dem, was wir jetzt bisher erreicht haben, sondern zu schauen, wo gibt's denn noch andere gesellschaftliche Strukturen und andere Szenen und andere kulturelle Kraftorte
die äh inkooperiert werden müssen, die vielleicht bisher selber auch so eine Berührungsangst mit uns haben
Wir haben das ja oft erlebt so als Nerds. Ganz zu Anfang war ja irgendwie komplett unter uns. So und dann hat sich das so über die Jahre etwas aufgelockert. Mittlerweile wird man da irgendwie ernst genommen.
Genauso sind die äh ist die Zurückhaltung geschwunden äh auf andere Szenen zuzugehen. Und ich denke, dass weil man halt umso mehr man solche anderen,
Denker mit,
reinholt und versucht da so 'n Konsens zu finden und sich darüber klar zu werden, dass dass man auch gemeinsam letzten Endes mehr erreichen kann,
umso besser.
Kontrolle ist gut, eine Mitmachdiszip,
Datenschutz und Privatsphäre sind komplexe Themen. Wie einzelne äh Entscheidungen unser Leben beeinflussen, ist im Voraus schwer zu sagen. Dieses interaktive Theaterstück,
mögliche Antworten auf die Frage, was wäre wenn? Wie verläuft die Karriere einer Wissenschaftlerin, wenn geistiges Eigentum abgeschafft wird? Findet die Studienabbrecherin noch einen Job,
Algorithmus als schwer vermittelbar eingestuft wird. Womit verdient die Influencerin ihr Geld, ist mir scheißegal, äh wenn Google und Facebook von der EU zerschlagen werden,
In Kontrolle ist gut, versuchen die drei Freundin Eva Carla und Susanne die Kontrolle über ihr Leben zu behalten, wären politisch kein Stein auf dem anderen bleibt,
ja
Aus der äh hier Kultursommer Wien zwanzig einundzwanzig äh Aufführung am dreiundzwanzigsten Juli ist zum Beispiel eine eine Aufführung am Naschmarkt.
Genau, das ist äh da wird jeder kennen, der schon mal in Wien war und es gibt dann nochmal irgendwie drei andere Termine im Karl-Marx-Hof im,
und in Aspern draußen,
und ja, wie gesagt, das ist ein Experiment. Äh ich hatte immer schon irgendwie eine gewisse Beziehung zum Theater, ähm aber ich habe eigentlich noch nie vorher Kunst gemacht,
und deswegen ist es auf jeden Fall ähm ja, unklar, ob das Ganze wirklich funktioniert, aber ähm,
Anschließend dann das, was Tim vorhergesagt hat. Ich erinnere mich noch, ich war mal auf einer Veranstaltung der Böll-Stiftung, wo halt auch Aktivisten, Journalisten und Theaterleiter zusammengebracht wurden,
Ich habe da so in meinem Selbstverständnis gesagt, ja und ein Aktivismus halt, wir versuchen Dinge halt einfach zu machen, sodass die Leute sich verstehen und der Theatermensch war total wütend. Nein, ich versuche, die Dinge schwierig zu machen, also diese Verdichtung, die da passiert,
ähm dass das äh ja, ist ein ganz anderer Ansatz als der den ich eigentlich so aus dem Aktivismus kenne. Ich habe zum Glück,
ähm zwei Leute gehabt, die mir zur Seite stehen und deswegen äh ist das nicht alles nur auf meinem Mist gewachsen.
Äh wer waren die zwei Leute?
Ähm das ist der Jakob Schindler Scholz und eine andere Person, die eine Nachbarin von mir ist und irgendwie der Grund ist, wieso ich das Ganze gemacht habe, weil die,
halt Intendantin ist und mehr oder weniger mich breit geschlagen hat, so sie wollte unbedingt was mit Netzpolitik machen
und ähm ja, hat mich halt überredet, dass ich äh dieses Stück mache.
Die ist Tina Leisch, die kennt man auch in Österreich, die hat Elfriede, Literaturnobelpreisträgerin, hat mal so ein Stück geschrieben, die Schutzbefohlenen,
und das hat sie mit echten Geflüchteten auf die Bühne gebracht zweitausendfünfzehn und sechzehn. Also die traut sich was, insofern der Rahmen ist einer der funktionieren kann, ob das am Ende,
werden wir sehen.
Die Leute hupen schon auf der Straße, Tim.
Hat jetzt hat jetzt jemand ein Tor geschossen und der ging an.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das jetzt grade getriggert hat. Ich habe nichts.
Es ist drei nach neun vielleicht.
Entschuldigung. Äh hattest du eine gute Nachricht?
Jetzt kann ich. Vielleicht ist.
Was? Das ist äh draußen hupen sie schon.
Die habe ich vorhin schon mal gestellt. Ich weiß nicht, ob du in der Lage warst, mittlerweile nachzugucken. Wir sind ja jetzt bei Folge vierhundert von diesem LNP,
Wahrscheinlich gibt's außer unseren vier Leuten noch ein paar Dutzend, die alle vierhundert Folgen gehört haben. Ähm,
Ich habe mal nachgeguckt, so Chaos, Radio, das gibt's ja schon ewig, aber ist monatlich gewesen, hat zweihundertneunundsechzig CRE, hat zweihunderteinundzwanzig,
Netzpolitik hat zweihundertzweiunddreißig, also alle irgendwo so zwischen zweihundert und dreihundert. Dieses Ding,
geplant wöchentlich. Hat jetzt nicht ganz die fünfhundertzwanzig nach zehn Jahren, aber immerhin vierhundert, das ist schon relativ viel Holz an Sendungen,
Ich würde mich mal persönlich noch interessieren, wenn's einfach rausbekommen war, äh ob LMP jetzt die Sendezeit von CRE überholt hat.
Er würde mich auch interessieren, dann will ich nämlich, der will ich nämlich rucki.
Das ging viel Lebenszeit drauf, die alle anzuhören.
Hundert.
Komm, deine Amazon-Liste war jetzt auch nicht unbedingt weniger als eine Bahnkarte, hundert.
Ich gucke mal. Ähm also.
Aber eine Menge Holz. Also zu.
CRE in der Summe, siebzehn Komma zwei Tage. Also wenn man alle Folgen durchhören würde, sind es siebzehn siebzehn.
Ich muss auch immer an dieses hier äh nehmen, wenn irgendwelche Leute sagen, oh ich habe überlegt, ich könnte im Urlaub alle LMP durchhören und denke so dazu, Kindchen, du brauchst ein Taschenrechner, weil das oder viel Urlaub.
Genau oder? Fünfundzwanzig Komma eins Tage um alle LMPs durchzuhören.
LMP fünfundzwanzig Tage CRE, siebzehn Tage tatsächlich, so weit mehr.
Ja
Wir das Monat voll.
Wir kamen ins Plaudern.
Was für ein CR äh in LNP null null eins, aber irgendwas mit wir versuchen das in einer Stunde, ne.
Das versuchen wir auch heute noch. Wir versuchen auch weitgehend unaufgeregt.
Ey, es können nicht alle immer du kannst halt nicht alle Ziele im Leben immer nur erreichen, weißt du, so manche Sachen, da muss halt echt lange üben.
Man braucht noch Ziele. Tja,
ist aber alles gesagt, oder?
Wo wird die Zukunft endet? Mit Thomas Theaterstück?
Ähm warum nicht? Was war noch was anderes?
Mehrwert Zukunft legen. Also achthunderttausend Folgen, wie lange machen wir das hier noch?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Das ist die Frage. Also im Moment macht's noch Spaß.
Also dazu habe ich auch mal noch eine Frage. Hat's denn immer Spaß gemacht? Ihr beiden, ihr seid doch auch wie so eine Art Ehe, oder? Mit Höhen und Tiefen,
manchmal lebt ihr euch und manchmal nicht so sehr.
Wer hat das auf jeden Fall schon mal ordentlich gefetzt.
Ja, das ist äh.
Das bleibt nicht aus.
Und und wenn hier, wenn ich hier zu so einer Vierhundert reinkomme, achtzehn Uhr und ich die Meterebene ist hier in so einem desolaten Zustand, sieht aus wie in so einem wie wie in so einem Windows äh Haushalt, ja.
Bier ist nicht kalt.
Vorhin erstmal eine Stunde um das Ding hier in die Gänge zu kriegen, äh dann äh denke ich schon ähm an an äh juristische Mittel.
Vielleicht mitm Expertennetz zusammen tun sollen. Ja, na ja, das ist halt irgendwie alles so eine Sache. Aber gut, ich meine,
Ich hatte am Anfang das Gefühl, mh das würde ja eigentlich ganz gut passen, weil ähm in gewisser Hinsicht,
denke ich, profitieren solche Projekte immer davon, wenn man dann irgendwie im Kern doch irgendwie,
zwar was gemeinsam hat, aber auch irgendwie mit unterschiedlichen Kakt Charakteren äh äh am Start ist. Und letzten Endes versucht, die Arbeitszeitung so zu machen, dass dass jeder so ein so ein so ein Ding hat,
was besser funktioniert so. Und das war eigentlich auch von Anfang an der Gedanke,
Linus steckt einfach in diesen Themen, auf eine Art und Weise drin und ist ja auf eine Art und Weise, äh auf der Spur, das kann ich gar nicht leisten,
gar nicht leisten, aber ich kann was anderes leisten. So, ich kann ich weiß, ich weiß.
Studio bereitstellen.
Her. Du, ich hatte jetzt zehn Jahre im Griff.
Studio ist bereit.
Also heute war wirklich aber.
Ist einfach Corona voll out.
Hier lag überall Staub auf den Dingern, das äh war.
Ja, das ist einfach nicht vorbereitet. Ich habe ja irgendwann mal in in dieser Corona-Phase habe ich mir einfach mal das ganze Setup ruiniert und ich muss es jetzt wirklich mal komplett neu machen, auch mit neuen Bedürfnissen und so. Das ist alles viel zu alt. Egal. Ähm,
wie weit kann's gehen, wo geht's hin? Also, ich denke, solang's ähm solange es läuten etwas gibt,
Solange es ähm Relevanz,
in der Lage ist und solange es von äh solange es Feedback gibt, die sagt,
Das gibt mir was und das, das, das, das, das, das hilft mir bei den Dingen,
solange hat es seine Berechtigung und solange kann es sich auch glaube ich daraus,
ernähren, also mental ernähren, dass wir auch die finanzielle Seite, aber das,
Das ist der andere Aspekt so, der, der so parallel läuft, aber wichtiger ist, dass man so das Gefühl hat, man erreicht da auch irgendwas. Und das ist natürlich jetzt so ein so ein Themenblock, der wo man das Gefühl hat, man erreicht irgendwie gar nichts. So auf.
Stell dir mal vor, wir hätten das nicht gemacht, wie ich dann aussehe.
Genau, genau das ist genau, das ist das ist nämlich der richtige Punkt. Wie sehe es eigentlich aus, wenn wir das alles nicht machen würden? Ich denke, das ist das ist etwas, worauf man schon mal schauen kann
Da ist schon so eine gewisse äh Resistenz auch in der Gesellschaft angelegt für
für noch noch noch krassere äh Strukturen und wenn man das zumindest ein bisschen eingeheckt bekommt, dann ist das schon mal schon mal was erreicht.
Vielleicht dazu noch hinzufügen. Also,
Also weitgehend unaufgeregt ist dieser Podcast nicht und äh der lebt natürlich auch, das wussten wir aber glaube ich auch nicht, als wir den gestartet haben,
dass der von einer bestimmten Dynamik zwischen uns beiden lebt, die wir anfangs auch noch nicht hatten. Ich habe irgendwann mal vor vielen Jahren mir die erste Folge angehört, wo ich dann irgendwie so,
Genau, wie so ein,
irgendjemand im ersten Tagesschau-Interview in der Metaebene sitze und denke so, jetzt lustiges Falsches sagen, ähm diese Hoffnung habe ich inzwischen aufgegeben, aber,
Ich glaube auch, dass der Podcast tatsächlich und das ist das meiste, das häufigste Feedback, was ich bekomme, ist ähm
Wir finden das oder ich finde das gut, weil wir oder wer auch immer, finde es gut, dass ihr diese Themen humorvoll und mit einer Lockerheit aufbereitet, obwohl die so scheiße sind. Und eigentlich hat oft dieses Thema,
Keiner Bock,
weil da gibt's ja wirklich selten 'ne 'ne interessante Sache hier dieser Jingle die gute Nachricht ist selten gehört so da war der meiste Staub drauf hier auf der Taste in der ganzen Meterebene.
Und äh insofern erfüllt das auch in meinen Augen eine politische Funktion, dass uns wahrscheinlich viele Leute eher für die Unterhaltung hören, als für,
Ich muss aber heute auch nochmal wissen, was in der Netzpolitik los war. Und äh,
Das sehe ich dann schon auch politisch, strategisch, dass wir das, dass ich das weiter äh füttern möchte, eine Mischung aus, ja, Unterhaltungsprogramm und politischem Bildungsprogramm und strammer äh Indoktrination,
anzubieten, ja?
So das das ist schon da sehe ich auch, dass wir da eine nach wie vor eine Lücke füllen, die im Bereich der Netzpolitik niemand anders,
grade bedient.
Und äh das äh sind das glaube ich auch, dass das tatsächlich wichtig ist. Hilft mir auch selber mit dem Mist noch klar zu kommen, gibt durchaus Momente, wo ich mir denke,
ähm,
Warum habe ich mir das eigentlich die ganzen Jahre angetan? Ich habe dem Scheiß ja eigentlich vor zehn Jahren den Rücken gekehrt, weil ich gedacht habe, ich möchte äh eine schönere Lebensinhalt haben mit der IT-Sicherheit. Das ist das einzige, größere Trauerspiel, als die,
was ich im Leben hätte finden können, aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Und ähm ja, also äh,
das ist so ein bisschen mein mein Anspruch, dass oder meine Hoffnung, das weiterzumachen. Interessant ist, wenn bei solchen Jubiläen denke ich dann immer auch zurück
in welchen Zeiten wir das geschafft haben, diese oder ich äh für Tim waren die Zeiten, glaube ich, nicht so hart. Aber so am am,
Anfang meiner äh beruflichen Tätigkeit im Bereich der IT-Sicherheit hatte ich jetzt nicht vierzig Stunden,
So, das waren äh andere Zustände
und da haben wir ja auch streckenweise wirklich äh in unterschiedlichen Zeitzonen und Tiefen nachts über
weitere Distanzen und Tim war in England und ich war in Asien und was wir da alles hingekriegt haben, das war schon immer so ein diebische Freude dafür zu sorgen, dass das niemand wusste.
Mhm.
Gelassenheit durch äh hohe Investitionen in Technik,
und ähm also ich würde sagen, die die härtesten Zeiten haben wir gewissermaßen hinter uns
Also zumindest, was, was äh meine Belastung angeht und wahrscheinlich auch äh deine Belastung, außer jetzt heute. Ich meine, das war wirklich fragwürdig in welchem Zustand das,
da müsste man auch mal drüber reden, also da da glaube ich, da schreiben wir nochmal ein da müssen wir nochmal gucken.
Ja, ich,
ist halt das Problem, wenn du ein eingefahrenes System hast, was du in zehn Jahren nicht anfasst und dann hört's auf zu funktionieren, dann weißt du gar nicht mehr, wovon und hin ist.
Andre und ich standen hier vor der Tür und im Sattel so, huch, ich, also ich muss sagen, ich war überhaupt nicht auf Männerbesuch.
Das hat er gesagt.
Herrenbesuch.
Herrenbesuch stimmt.
Zehn Jahres Rosenhochzeit lese ich auf äh Wikipedia.
Große kriegt er nicht.
Ja, aber klar, also immer mal wieder äh äh reibt es und ich glaube auch tatsächlich, wenn ich das richtig erinnere, Tim, war das wirklich auch so dieses sogenannte verflixte siebte Jahr, wo wir da mal äh richtig Reibung hatten, ja,
Aber von Reibung kommt hier auf Ärmel.
Das hast du schön gesagt.
Wir haben ja noch, wir haben noch so ein paar Fragen, die wir uns eigentlich noch stellen wollten. Was denn? Ne, äh, wieso eigentlich guten Morgen, das weiß ich zum Beispiel nicht mehr.
Heute nicht passiert, das erste Mal, glaube ich.
Haben wir die erste Folge auch schon mit guten Morgen angefangen?
Das kam, ich habe neulich, ich habe ja neulich mal diese ganzen Transkripte gemacht und dadurch ist sehr viele alte Sendungen reingehört. Äh nee, das das kam dann erst irgendwie später.
Folge acht oder oder.
Ja, weiß ich, jetzt.
Nicht noch später, weil als ich in der Elf hier war, da war das schon das Ding und ja.
Bist du sicher? Ja. Da bin ich mir jetzt zum Beispiel nicht äh so.
Weiß das noch.
Da hatten wir noch kein Intro, ne? Da hatten wir noch keinen Intro-Dingle. Wir hatten ja nichts. Werden nicht. Nee, sollten.
Aber du hast Recht. In der elf haben wir das gemacht, aber ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob wir das so durchgezogen haben. Hm, echt, elf war das schon. Popcornpotenzial. Und in der,
Okay, in der in der in der zehn auch. Echt? Also es war nicht so ganz so regelmäßig, es war so ein bisschen on off mäßig und irgendwie hat sich das so eingefangen.
Das war auf jeden Fall auf Tims äh Mist gewachsen, weil ich erinnere mich, äh wie er mir diesen Vorschlag eröffnete. Und dann, ich glaube, erst mit dem Jingle kam es, dass wir dann auch diese Intro äh Sprüchchen da.
Ja, das kam dann später noch.
Es kam dann noch später, ne? Das kam, glaube ich, erst mit.
Kam dann genau da, genau das war das, was noch später kam. Es kam das gute Morgen und dann kam das andere und sowieso langsam tastet man sich an seinen äh Format ran.
Und da weiß ich zum Beispiel nicht, wer hatte eigentlich die Idee zu dem Intro? Also ich, ich weiß, dass ich diese Liste der Tagesschaumelodien.
Das hatte ich rausgesucht. Mhm.
Das hast du, ne? Hm, weil da werden, gibt's auch immer mal.
Viele immer noch nicht.
Genau, da gibt's immer mal wieder so einen Tweet, dass irgendjemand auf auf YouTube über eine alte Tagesschau stolpert und sich denkt.
Genau, das war nämlich der Hack, also.
Sunlyd.
Der Ursprung des Lokbrut Nest Politik Intros war halt der Tagesschau ganz am,
am Anfang, also der Erste, der sich dann sehr schnell, ich glaube, in ein oder zwei Jahre später hatte sich dann eben in, im Wesentlichen in das verwandelt, was es heute noch ist, was ja dann so verschiedene Wandlungsstufen genau hat. Das Ding haben wir irgendwie genommen
eine Weile und dann war's halt so dieses so, hm, ja, okay, man bräuchte schon mal was eigenes,
Ja und dann habe ich das hier äh dem Florian Airbag äh gegeben, der so mein Intro-Spezi ist und habe gesagt, so, ich will eigentlich genau äh Same Same but Different und da kam dann halt das Ding raus, so wie's jetzt ist, ne. Und ich hoffe demnächst dann auch mal ein Auto,
Und ja, ich bin äh nach wie vor sehr äh zufrieden damit, weil es halt so dieses Nachrichtending irgendwie wohnt und trotzdem ist es halt auch sehr,
an digitalisiert. Ja.
Schneiden wir eigentlich in den Episoden. Ich kann äußerst selten.
Selten, aber es kommt vor.
Der Hauptgrund wann das vorkommt ist wenn wir irgendwie Gäste zuschalten oder ich muss mal auf Toilette oder Nase putzen oder es ruft jemand an verkacken.
Als jetzt Impfzentrum angerufen hat, war Tim auf einmal nervös,
Gelassenheit der Streit hier jetzt, dass du eine Gelassenheit aus, ja? Solche äh Dinge und ich glaube, es ist in den vierhundert Episoden würde ich jetzt sagen,
vier oder fünf Mal realistische Schätzung, korrigiere mich vorgekommen, dass ich nachher gesagt habe, pass auf, was ich da gesagt habe, geht so nicht, das müssen wir rausnehmen,
Würde ich jetzt also so einmal.
Das ja, ich würde das Potenzial auf zehn Mal schätzen so, aber äh aber ist schon wirklich so die Ausnahme und dann ist es eher so ein,
man hat sich dann eben so ein bisschen in ähm in Rage geredet oder sagen wir mal so ein bisschen auch vergessen, dass wir ja dann doch in diesen intimen Situationen, die es ja letzten Endes sind,
doch dann zu einer fünfstelligen äh sprechen.
Da passieren dann halt Dinge, dann dann dann sich mal gegenseitig mit Scherzen hoch und dann will man noch einen draufhauen und dann denkt man irgendwie so, okay, das war jetzt einer, den können wir unter uns bringen, aber nicht vor einem.
Publikum. Ja. Das stimmt.
Größeren Publikum. Das geht nicht. Das äh äh.
Weil's einfach in dem Moment keiner nachvollziehen könnte, auch wenn's eigentlich nicht so gemeint war.
Ja, weil der auch teilweise also teilweise habe ich kann ich ganz klar sagen, ob ich da über die Grenzen des guten Geschmacks äh übertreten? Will man mir jetzt ja gar nicht,
Also kann man sich ja gar nicht bei mir gar nicht vorstellen, dass mir sowas mal passieren würde.
Ruhig und unauf.
Nein! Ja, ganz äh ganz locker hier.
Gibt's auch Folgen, die nie ausgestrahlt wurden?
Ja. Äh also das da weiß ich jetzt auch nicht, da würde ich sagen, das ist vielleicht ein oder zwei Mal passiert, dass wir oder maximal dreimal,
dass wir eine Sendung gemacht haben in der Regel mit Gästen, äh in der Regel mit Gästen Remote, zugeschaltet, wo wir den Flow so dermaßen nicht hinbekommen haben,
das kriegen wir auch im können wir jetzt nicht im Schnitt korrigieren, gar nichts. Das ist einfach.
Nochmal.
Die machen wir nochmal. Ähm,
Beispiel, ich ich nehme mal ein Beispiel, wo das nicht der Fall war. Aber warum so etwas passiert? Das war die Folge mit äh Markus Mengengs, gar nicht lange her. Mit dem habe ich halt schon seit langer Zeit einen persönlichen Austausch und eine persönliche Ebene und viel
Wissen untereinander und viele Witze, die wir beide,
wo wir nicht mehr viel sagen müssen und so, ne, so ein Insider Verhältnis. Ähm und die Sendung war, fand ich auch so knapp an der Grenze,
dass ich dachte, okay ähm,
Das hat jetzt nicht also das hat, wir haben am Ende super positives Feedback für die Sendung bekommen, ne? Aber wo ich so dachte, oh ähm das ist hier fast schief gegangen, dass das nicht mehr für diese Größe des Publikums ähm.
Einen Wertbeitrag ist, hat sich dann nachher ganz anders herausgestellt, aber die war, da hatte ich zum Beispiel das Gefühl und in anderen Fällen war das mal so, in der Düssel eine Regelsendung, wo wo,
ich den Gästen oder Tim, den Gästen, so nahe ist, dass wir es nicht mehr schaffen,
Ich kann das eh nicht gut, eine Gesprächsführung zu machen, die für ein Publikum,
zugänglich ist. Das kann ich total selber solange nur ich rede, kriege ich das hin oder ich mit Tim, aber wenn da eine andere Person ist, noch dazu eine, mit der ich persönlichen Bezug habe, dann äh bin ich da der Faktor, der da zerstört,
und äh Tim nicht, der kann das. Aber äh da da haben wir, glaube ich, über die vierhundert Folgen mal ein, ein oder andere seltene Mal gehabt,
Die haben wir aber dann immer neu aufgenommen.
Danke. Ja, das ist auch die die Idee des Logbuchs. Also, ich glaube, es gibt selten Themen, die wir nicht behandelt haben. Es war eher eine Frage des wie und wann, aber das ob es irgendwie recht schnell geklärt.
Eine Vollständigkeitserklärung würde ich jetzt nicht unterzeichnen. Ich merke das bei mir am Medienkonsum und in dem, was wir schaffen, bei Netzbotekorb zu berichten. Äh alles, was in das Themenfeld,
gehört, schaffen wir nicht und das ist heutzutage auch nicht mehr möglich, ist meine These, aber zumindest der Grundstock, die Auswahl ist relativ repräsentativ und relativ wichtig und manchmal holt man Dinge nach, ähm,
und meistens ist das schon ein solider Überblick.
Ich bin da ja natürlich auch froh, dass wir dann äh nach und nach so Expertinnen wie Julia Reeder einfach äh auch jetzt inzwischen über Kurzfall und kurze Abstimmung äh in die Sendung bekommen,
um um Themen zu behandeln, die anstrengend sind oder
Patrick Breyer, freue ich mich auch, ne, wenn ich denn sehe, okay, der nördet sich in Thema ein. Äh ich lese jede Pressemitteilung von denen oder äh der Ralf Benrath, solche Leute, dass äh ist natürlich dann schon eine große Erleichterung.
Wenn du sagst, okay, shit, dit ist jetzt hier ein ganz großes Thema, da da müssen wir die mal fragen.
Gibt's noch Fragen?
Ja, wo sind die Fragen eigentlich her?
Hat der Tim hier ins Bett äh.
Hä? Das waren so Fragen, die ich da irgendwie zur kurzen Vorbereitung.
Ich habe das nicht gemacht.
In äh äh.
Ja, das war so leer. Ich habe mir gedacht, ein bissel was brauchen wir,
weiß nicht, wo werden wir ohne Podcasts? Wo werden wir ohne Podcasts? Ist es irgendwie ich glaube, darüber haben wir eh schon fast gesprochen.
Nee, die finde ich, das finde ich also ich glaube tatsächlich, ohne Podcast wäre ich,
Also äh wär ich auf jeden Fall einen ganz anderen Weg im Leben gegangen.
Ja gut, das stimmt bei mir auch.
Und da waren auf jeden Fall die ganzen CCC, Radio Express, Chaos, Radio, diese ganzen Sachen waren da prägend ähm und wenn es das nicht gegeben hätte, ja, dann wäre vielleicht eine Humboldt Uni geblieben.
Landesverrat gab's diesen komischen Spruch von Jerodin, Markus hat mein Leben verändert, aber eigentlich so die drei, wie wir hier sitzen, äh dem Prittlauf hat unser Leben verändert äh durch Meterebene und CRE,
Und jetzt.
Vor allem könnte ich nicht schlafen oder.
Das hast du schon ein paar Mal erzählt mit deinen drei Fragezeichen, Raubkopien. Privat.
Na und das Letzte wäre so irgendwie ja, wie ist es, Netzpolitik zu machen, aber das sind die, die Zugänge, die wir, die wir haben und ich glaube schon, das Feld,
ist spannend geblieben. Ich bin ja hängengeblieben, weil es das erste war, was nach drei Monaten nicht langweilig wurde,
Ich weiß, wenn wenn wir uns zurückerinnern, wir haben gerade viel über zweitausendneunzehn elf gerädert, da waren noch irgendwie so ein Thema pro Jahr oder pro Legislaturperiode und heute haben wir irgendwie so dreißig, vierzig Gesetze in einem Jahr,
da reinfallen und das ist nur in jedem beliebigen Land.
Oder drei pro Woche, wenn ne, wenn so eine Legislaturperiode zu Ende geht.
Zehn diese Woche.
Oder zehn.
Das ist wirklich hart.
Da habe ich jetzt noch eine Frage an Linus, wenn du gerade gesagt hast,
aufgehört, um IT Security Politik zu machen, aber genau in der selben Zeit hast du bei LNP angefangen und das hast du jetzt zehn Jahre durchgezogen,
Wie passt denn das zusammen.
Ja, das also ähm,
also der Job, den ich da eingestiegen bin, war durchaus stressig. Das hatte ich mir vielleicht auch äh ähm anfangs noch unterschätzt,
ähm und ich war natürlich auch auf eine Weise froh, dem Thema irgendwie so ein bisschen,
nah bleiben zu können. Es ist ja so, äh Judith Judith Horchert hat sich da tierisch äh drüber nee, nicht tierisch drüber aufgeregt, aber sie war ein bisschen gekränkt. Ähm,
Also ich siehe nämlich bei der Logbuch Netzpolitik zweihundertsechsundfünfzig oder was? Die zweihundert, wo sie zu Gast war, ähm,
Angekündigt habe, mit irgendjemand muss auch die Meldungen schreiben, die wir verlesen, ne? Und sie dann sagte so, hör mal, pass mal auf, ne, ich bin der Ressortleiterin bei Spiegel Netzwerk und wir machen hier keine Meldungen, wir arbeiten journalistisch, hat sie auch recht gehabt.
Aber mir war ich dachte damals noch so ein bisschen so, ach ja, weißt du,
hier äh Mobile Max oder nee das hieß damals noch Mobile, Max oder Freakshow, habe ich gesagt, gut, die lesen den ganzen Tag äh,
wie ihre Apple News und äh einmal die Woche oder alle zwei Wochen quatschen die drüber. Und da habe ich mir gedacht, das mache ich ja auch. Also es ist auch tatsächlich so, viele fragen mich so, ja äh wie viel Vorbereitungszeit ist Lokbuch Netzpolitik?
Hm.
Die Antwort ist, nicht einfach zu machen, weil äh ich müsste jetzt trennen, was ist Lokbuch Netzpolitik Vorbereitungszeit und was ist mein ganz normaler Medienkonsum?
Und meistens,
Ist es, dass ich einfach nur ähm in all meinen Browsern, die ich so nutze, einen Knopf habe? Das ist was für Logbuch Netzpolitik. Die Artikel lese und am Ende nur noch kurz sortieren muss, was die Woche oder in der Zeit war. Ähm.
Wenn ich das aber mal eine Zeit lang nicht mache, weil ich Urlaub mache, dann habe ich natürlich auch äh lange Vorbereitungszeiten. Aber,
insgesamt also weiß ich nicht, ist jetzt natürlich schwer zu sagen, aber diese Themen, ich lese das wirklich aus eigenem Interesse,
Aus eigenem Interesse und nicht, weil ich denke, okay, ich muss immer gucken, ob eine Presseanfrage an den CCC kommt, die ich beantworten muss oder ich muss immer am Ball bleiben, damit ich die nächste Logbuch Netzkritik machen kann, sondern ich lese sie auch wirklich aus eigenem Interesse,
und äh so habe ich mir dann Logbuch Netzpolitik eben auch,
relativ einfach vorgestellt und es ist in den meisten Zeiten halt auch relativ einfach gewesen, weil ich die Themen ohnehin auf dem Schirm habe. Aber manchmal gibt's halt auch anstrengende Wochen,
wo ich dann, was weiß ich, im komplizierten Projekt bin und dazu gar nichts mehr komme und dann ist Lokbuch Netzpolitik halt auf einmal eine Last,
und dann muss ich irgendwie noch spät nachts Nachrichten, schlechte Nachrichten lesen und das ist dann nicht ganz so cool.
Also diesen Wochenrhythmus durchzuhalten ist für dich ganz schön tough. Äh ja, da braucht man wirklich eine ziemliche,
Disziplin und ich merke das auch immer, wie ich an anderen Formaten manchmal scheitere und dann will man irgendwie auch nicht. Man ist jetzt auch nicht so oder so, dass wir jetzt gleich
durch den Schlamm gezogen werden, wenn jetzt meine Sendung nicht rauskommt so, aber man will sich ja auch selber
da treu bleiben auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen Seite sind bestimmte Themen dann halt auch irgendwann schon auch nicht mehr spannend, wenn man sie nicht regelmäßig begleitet. Das ist einfach eine ganz andere Art und Weise. Der Begleitung
gewisser Hinsicht, also wo ich ein bisschen stolz drauf bin, was, glaube ich, am Anfang von Podcast-Projekten viele auch übersehen, ist die Einschätzung,
Wie oft eigentlich ein Format erscheinen muss, die ist schon entscheidend so, also Wochen,
Regelmäßigkeit ist was ganz anderes, als eine zwei Wochen Regelmäßigkeit als ein drei Wochen Regelmäßigkeit.
Da die richtige Balance zu finden ist schwierig und dann nimmt man sich halt auch einiges mit Freunden. Es gibt ja sogar Leute, die täglich oder irgendwie zweimal, dreimal die Woche äh was machen, das das, das, das ist schon totaler Ausnahmezustand in gewisser Hinsicht.
Ja. Also ich finde, wir haben's da im Großen und Ganzen ganz gut getroffen. Ich meine, vierhundert Sendungen, zehn Jahre, gut, wir haben ja noch nicht zehn Jahre voll. Die haben wir dann im im wann haben wir die voll? November, September.
September oder so, hatte ich vorhin geguckt.
Ähm gut, kommen ja noch ein paar.
Achtundzwanzigster zehnter zwanzig elf.
Ja, also was weiß ich, aber haltbar, es gibt ja immer Sommerpause und solche solche Geschichten, das passt schon. Und das ist ähm funktioniert noch und mal gucken, wie lange es weiter funktioniert.
Ich wollte dich eigentlich fragen, ob's das geworden ist, was du dir am Anfang überlegt hast, aber ich weiß, dass du da sehr ähm fluide bist,
wir starten mal ein Projekt und gucken, wo sich das hin entwickelt und offensichtlich hast du noch genug Lust dran und Bock drauf, trotz aller Ehestreitigkeiten, das weiter durchzuziehen, aber zu unterm Strich ist es schon eins.
Ist es genau das geworden, was ich wollte. Okay. Also das war schon das, was ich so im Sinn hatte. Weil dieses auch die,
Also ich finde das Format spielt sehr gut die Stärke von Podcasts aus.
Und das, das ist vielleicht auch das, was so ein bisschen den Reiz macht, weil ich persönlich und das war so auch so ein Antriebsfehler. Ich dachte mir so, ja okay, nett, politisches Geschehen, alles ganz interessant. Man kann da viel lesen,
Aber in dem Moment, wo man dann irgendwie nicht mehr so richtig,
Interessiert ist, dann reißt es bei Textversorgung schnell ab. Und Podcasts haben einfach den Vorteil,
oder zumindest finde ich es, dass der die primäre Dienstleistung, die man über Podcast sehr gut
liefern kann, ist diese fortwährende Kontextualisierung und dieses fortwährende Kommentieren und äh das ist das man doch recht faul sein kann beim Konsumieren dieser Information,
kommt einem schon irgendwie entgegen. Klar kann man auch einen Podcast so unaufmerksam hören, dass man gar nichts mitbekommt. Aber wenn man jetzt einfach sagt, so ich könnte mir jetzt nicht
fünfzig Artikel dazu durchlesen so, aber ich lasse mir gerne mal zusammenfassen, irgendwie was
diese Woche wieder äh an histopischen äh Kram passiert ist und wenn Leute dazu auch noch ein bisschen kichern können, geht's mir gleich viel besser. Es ist schon dann auch irgendwie eine spezifische Dienstleistung. Und ich glaube, an der Stelle erfüllt das Format dann äh die Erwartungen ganz gut.
Das ist halt einfach die der Vorteil. Und deswegen, wie Linus das Fulda auch schon gesagt hat, deswegen ist es, glaube ich, auch grundsätzlich wichtig,
gilt für alle Formate, dass man den Humor dabei nicht verliert. Also es ist, dass man, dass man eben auch äh sichtbar machen, äh sichtbar macht, dass man eben so,
auch irgendwie potenziell überfordert ist mit allem, dass man nicht immer irgendwie ist, was er, was einem ja gut recherchierte Artikel irgendwie immer versuchen
oder nicht versuchen weiß zu machen, aber was so so Nebeneffekt ist, so dieses so hier wir haben total die Scheckungen und äh das ist das, was wir derzeit so alles rausgefunden haben und das weiß auch jeder.
Den Eindruck zum Beispiel vermitteln wir.
So und da kann dann jeder auch so ein bisschen mitführen und so so ja, ich bin auch total überfordert. So gut, dass es den auch so geht.
Hm.
Andererseits kann man aber auch eben diese diese tumpe äh Idiotie der Politik auch gleichermaßen dann äh dadurch auch darstellen und irgendwie auch klarmachen, dass so der
der Endgegner auch nicht so groß und und und muskulös ist es, wie er sich selber immer geriert, sondern dass sie in gewisser Hinsicht auch angreifbar sind und äh auch nur dummes Zeug kriegen.
In gewisser Hinsicht auch angreifbar, ist ein sehr schöner Euphonismus. Das ist eh, also das ist eine Sache, die jetzt sich nicht durch den Podcast, aber irgendwie im Leben gelernt habe, ist, dass sie dass egal, wo du hinkommst, die alle irgendwie nur mit Wasser kochen, wenn du Glück hast,
Wenn du Glück hast, nehmen die Wasser und ähm das ähm ja,
das ist so eine so eine Erkenntnis. Die musste ich irgendwie bekommen. Ich habe irgendwie, ich habe irgendwie tatsächlich gehofft in meinem Leben, da kommt irgendwann nochmal was, wo ich wo ich wirklich mit Profis zu tun habe. Aber ähm.
War nicht so.
Nee. Also ist schon,
Es es macht ja auch Sinn, sich wirklich mal über diese Strukturen Gedanken zu machen, unter denen jeweilige die jeweiligen Institutionen oder die jeweiligen Büros und,
Koalition und Opposition und sonst was agieren. Das sind ja auch Dinge, wo du äh Andre,
ähm noch viel mehr Einsichten auch gesammelt hast in den letzten zehn Jahren jetzt ungefähr als ich,
über was was läuft da wirklich zwischen dem und dem und hier und äh ähm Mitarbeitern und äh was die SPD gerade mit der CDU, CSU oder,
Also Deal ist natürlich also jetzt Deal nicht im Sinne Be Art of the Deal oder vielleicht doch genau in dem Sinne so. Äh und äh Thomas,
du hast mir auch sehr viel erzählt von den politischen Geschehnissen in Österreich. Die werden ja durchaus in den letzten Jahren auch äh turbulenter als in Deutschland, ne. Wir haben,
seit sechzehn Jahren das Gleiche in unterschiedlichen Farben, den kompletten Regenbogen haben wir nie erreicht, wo jetzt noch mal dem Tagrechnung zu tragen, aber,
Ja, so.
Das Wichtige ist an allen Ecken, es sind immer nur Menschen. Politik wird von Menschen gemacht,
Wirklichkeit ist der ganze Podcast hier ein Weg auch, das wieder menschlich zu greifen,
und auch wenn man dahinter steht, auch wenn man vielleicht sogar selber dran beteiligt ist in der einen oder anderen Form,
ja, Hochachtung vor diesen Dingen ist eigentlich nicht angebracht. Ähm man sieht, dass da ja halt auch Leute mit ihren Motiven versuchen ähm die Runden zu kommen und,
vor allem eben Selbsterhalt, dass das stärkste politische Motiv, was es gibt.
Und versuch mal, versuch mal mit zehntausend Nebeneinkünften im Monat über die Runden zu kommen,
weißt du? Ja du, das ist ein hartes Brot. Äh ja, guck dir den Jens Spahn an, der will auch nur über die Runden kommen, ja.
Das Schlimme ist, die glauben das wirklich. Die schlimme ist, das ist nicht so, ich kann mich jetzt ausrasten, ich hab's geschafft. Ich glaube, die Einstellung findest du bei den seltesten Menschen mit Macht.
In den Kreisen, äh wo die verkehren, sind das auch ganz kleine arme Würstchen,
es ist ja wirklich, die kommen sicher wie die Doofen vor.
Promo Vision. Ich habe vorne, dass du mich angesprochen hast. Versucht, eine komische Überleitung zu machen, aber jetzt passiert tatsächlich, also je weniger man weiß, wie Würste und Gesetze gemacht werden, desto besser schläft man,
meint ihr, es geht euren Hörer innen genauso? Je weniger man weiß wie dieses Lo,
kommt, desto besser ist es, Hauptsache der stimmt.
Das sollten diese Sendung die veröffentlichen.
Sagen so, bei den Würsten konnte ich wenigstens zweitausenddrei Vegetarier werden.
Nicht. Aber äh die Podcast hältst du auch schon zehn Jahre durch.
Oh man. Leute, ich glaube, wir haben das Ende erreicht. Das war super.
Abgewürgt, aber erst rechtzeitig zur zweiten Halbzeit.
Nein, perfekt. Dritte, dritte Halbzeit ist entscheidend. So, ich habe fünf Kilo Glitter,
In allen Farben. Dritte Halbzeit machen wir heute hier. Also draußen. Thomas, vielen Dank für alle deine Beiträge zu Logbuch Netzpolitik
Ähm vielen Dank für dein Engagement in
Edri und Epicenter Works und die vielen politischen Erfolge, die wir jetzt in dieser Sendung gar nicht mehr oder gar nicht so behandelt haben, die du ja gerade in Österreich, insbesondere auch gefeiert hast und auch auf der EU-Ebene,
Andre, vielen Dank für das Kompensierende. Danke, dass du so schön meine Fußstoffe bei Nestpopic org getreten bist. Für äh wirklich ein.
Auf dem Team von Netzpolitik steht auch äh übernimmt für Linus, wenn er nicht da ist,
entweder zu Gast oder als Vertretung von Linus, wenn dieser verhindert ist. Ja, vielen Dank.
Da weiß ich nichts von, das muss nachher gebracht haben.
Nein, ich habe äh Andre, ich habe es ja schon öfter gesagt, du hast äh du persönlich hast äh Journalismus und Politik in Deutschland auf viele Ebenen geprägt dafür. Vielen herzlichen Dank und alle meine Anerkennung.
Na ja, wollen wir's ein bisschen tiefer hängen. Danke, danke und uns alle und danke auch für viele Folgen, die ich mit vielen Podcasts verbringen durfte.
Und Tim, danke, dass das mit der Metaebene heute noch in Griff bekommen hast. Mach dir nichts draus.
Hauptsache, es funktioniert.
Ach so und danke für zehn Jahre Logbuch Netzpolitik. Zehn Jahre sind's ja noch nicht, vierhundert Folgen Logbuchnetzpolitik mit allen Ups and Downs. Äh das ist äh die, die längste und wichtigste Beziehung meines Lebens.
Ich doch. Was war das vorhin für eine Hochzeit? Ich habe den.
Es hat, hat so was.
Rosen oder so.
Was sind schon Drogen, was sind schon Frauen, wenn man auch eine Podcast-Beziehung haben kann.
Wenn man sie wöchentlich über Logbuch, über Netzpolitik unterhalten kann, das ist.
Aber eine Frage hätte ich noch an Hörerinnen. Ich weiß noch nicht, wo die gut zu beantworten äh wäre.
Immer in den Kommentaren.
Einer der gefühlt nicht allzu viele Personen, die tatsächlich alle diese vierhundert Folgen gehört haben. Äh ich habe das Gefühl, da gibt's mehrere Dutzend. Äh ich habe nicht so ganz ich weiß mir nicht so ganz, ob's da mehrere hundert,
das ist jetzt nicht so einfach im Kommentar plus eins zu sagen oder so,
Mittel, das auszudrücken habe ich nicht, aber das wäre schon mal interessant, wer jetzt was war das Wort? Fünfundzwanzig Stunden am Stück.
Nicht am am Stück ist hart, also die.
Nee, in der Summe fünfundzwanzig am Stück, aber verteilt über zehn Jahre oder auch in äh anderen äh Intervallen gehört hat.
Ich kann meine einfache Sache sagen, das das könnten mehrere tausend Leute sein.
In der Theorie. Das sind die, die jetzt runtergeladen haben.
Äh nee und das liegt ganz einfach daran, dass dieser Logbuch Netzpolitik Podcast irgendwie mit der ersten Folge fünftausend Abonnenten hatte.
Ist natürlich auch das ist so ein bisschen der Prit-Love-Bonus, äh für den andere Podcast halt äh lange arbeiten mussten, aber äh
oder was auch immer, welche Erwähnungen Tim irgendwo geschaffen hat, hat, glaube ich, zu Beginn dazu geführt, dass wir äh,
umgehen ein paar tausend Hörerinnen hatten. Und jetzt wäre meine Hoffnung, dass wir vielleicht ein paar von denen äh halten konnten.
Zehn Jahre jede Sendung.
Als ich jede Sendung kann ich mir irgendwie nicht so richtig, aber ich habe ja noch nicht mal jede Sendung gehört.
Den Eindruck hatte ich auch mal.
Ehepaar.
Okay, let's let's go. Äh.
Also ihr könnt in den Kommentaren anmerken, dass ihr alle Sendungen gehört habt und dann.
Glauben wir euch das einfach.
Machen wir kommen noch so ein paar Quizfragen.
Okay. Dank dir Linus, danke euch.
Alles Gute zum, na, nicht fast Geburtstag, zum Jubiläum.
Mal gucken, ob wir zu dem zu dem kalendarischen dann auch mal wieder die Sache mit diesen Events machen können. Das ist äh glaube ich doch ein bisschen offen, aber irgendwann.
Musste noch ein bisschen aufräumen in der Mitte.
Haben wir auch das.
Also das zehnjährige Jubiläum steht auf jeden Fall unter dem Motto Delta.
Tschüss, das war's, bis bald.
Tschau, tschau, vielen Dank.